EMERGENCY HAD TO PROTECT ALL OF
US WE ARE LIMITING A
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN
ADHERING TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
IT BASE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE ADJUSTMENTS
TO OUR NORMAL PRACTICES TO
ENSURE. THAT THE PUBLIC HAS
ACCESS TO OUR LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING OUR
HEARING HERE IN THE CAPITAL-
BUT WE WILL HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND OUR
LEGEND LET'S OFFICE PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY. AND REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS YOU KNOW THE
DRILL- AND WHEN- I RECOGNIZE
YOU YOU WILL ON MUTE BUT THEN-
R. I. T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU
BACK ON MUTE. TO ALLOW PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ALLOWED WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TWO TWO HEARING ROOMS. THIS ONE
THAT WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW IN AN
AUXILIARY. AND WE ALSO WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THROUGH THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. I WILL
GIVE YOU THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER NOW. IT IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN THREE THREE SIX
FOUR FOUR THREE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT TWO SIX
EIGHT FOUR TWO EIGHT- THERE ARE
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON THE
SENATE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE- SO
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED AND WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE HEARING PROCESSING
CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE
TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY- CLEARLY WITH THESE
TECHNOLOGIES THERE CAN BE LAG
TIME SO PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL
AND PATIENT. AND LET US SEE NOW
IF WE HAVE GOT A QUORUM YET WE
DON'T- SO AS IF THERE ARE ANY-
SENATORS WHO ARE HEARING ME NOW
WHO ARE IN THEIR OFFICES IF YOU
COULD COME DOWN TO THE FLOOR SO
THAT WE CAN ESTABLISH QUORUM
THAT WOULD BE GREAT- WE ONLY
NEED A FEW MORE- BUT WHILE WE
ARE WAITING WE CAN START AS OUR
SUBCOMMITTEE AND I WILL- LET
YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE DOING TODAY
WE HAVE TWO BILLS THE EDUCATION
TRAILER BILL AND A BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR. WE WILL HAVE A MUCH
LARGER PACKAGE NEXT WEEK.
COMPONENTS OF THE EDUCATION
TRAILER BILL INCLUDE AMONG
OTHER THINGS FULLY PAYING OFF
THE DEFERRALS. THE- THE STEPS
FOR OUR MOVE TO UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN AND
ALSO TO UNIVERSAL SCHOOL MEALS.
CHILD CARE IS NOT INCLUDED IN
THIS PARTICULAR TRAILER BILL IN
PART BECAUSE WE HAVE MOVED IT
TO A DIFFERENT DEPARTMENT AND
IT WILL BE A SEPARATE BILL AND
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE STILL
FINALIZING THE LANGUAGE SO IT
IS WHAT WE WILL BE TAKING UP
NEXT WEEK. THE HOWEVER DOES IN
MANY OF THESE OTHER THINGS THE
FINDINGS RELATED TO IT WAS
PASSED IN THE PRIMARY BUDGET
BILL THAT WE HAVE ALREADY ACTED
ON. NOW IT IS NECESSARY FOR US
TO MOVE THE EDUCATION TRAILER
BILL THIS WEEK. TO ENSURE THAT
FUNDING IS INCLUDED FOR THE
SCHOOLS IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
GOES OUT IN A TIMELY MANNER.
NOW IT LOOKS LIKE WE DO HAVE-
FORM NOW SO I'M GOING TO ASK MR
STEPPED IN SHOCK. OUR
CONSULTANT TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR SKINNER I'M HERE
SKINNER HERE NELSON LISTEN
PRESIDENT COPYRIGHT. COPYRIGHT
HERE CORTESE OR DOES HE HEAR
DOLLY. DOLLY YEAH DOLLY HERE
THE ROSWELL EGGMAN. A MAN HERE
GROWTH. COM LONGER LAYERED
REQUIRE MELENDEZ MELINDA'S HERE
MAN MAN HERE NEWMAN NEWMAN HERE
UNTIL ABOUT JOHN BEL HERE PAN.
AND HERE STERN BY CAL SKI. ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM SO LET ME CONTINUE WITH
WHAT WE'RE DOING TODAY SO AS I
INDICATED THE EDUCATION TRAILER
BILL WE NEED TO MOVE THIS WEEK
SO THAT THE FUNDING FOR OUR K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS GOES OUT
IN A TIMELY MANNER. NOW WE WILL
HEAR BOTH BILLS SO WE'LL HEAR%
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND COURSE YOU ALL CAN ASK ANY
QUESTIONS OR MAKE COMMENTS.
PRIOR TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT AND
THEN WE WILL TURN TO PUBLIC
COMMENT ALLOW FOR THAT AND THEN
WE WILL TAKE THE MOTIONS AND
VOTE ON THE BILLS. SO BEFORE I
ASK DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
PRESENT. VICE CHAIR NELSON
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE ANY
COMMENTS. OKAY WE WILL THEN. GO
TO THE PRESENTATION OF OUR
FIRST BILL AB ONE SIXTY ONE
WHICH IS THE BUDGET BILL JUNIOR
DEPARTMENT FINANCE ARE YOU
READY. ASK AFTERNOON THANKS SO
MUCH MISLI YES THANK YOU- THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND- MISTER
VICE CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- ERIC LEE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I'LL BE
PRESENTING ON AB ONE SIXTY ONE
WHICH IS A BUDGET BILL JUNIOR.
AND AMENDS THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT. SPECIFICALLY
THIS BILL AUTHORIZES THE FULL
AMOUNT OF FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
GENERAL FUND THAT'S CURRENTLY
SCHEDULED FOR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE TO BE ACCELERATED TO
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO FOR. FIRE
PREVENTION AND FOREST
RESILIENCE- SHOULD
CIRCUMSTANCES NECESSITATE THAT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. THIS ALSO
INCREASES THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
TO BE PROVIDED TO COUNTIES FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
GUBERNATORIAL RECALL ELECTION
FROM TWO HUNDRED FIFTEEN POINT
TWO MILLION TO TWO HUNDRED
FORTY THREE. POINT SIX MILLION-
REFLECTING THE REVISED COST
ESTIMATES PROVIDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. TO THE
LEGISLATURE GOVERNOR AND
SECRETARY OF STATE ON JULY ONE
OUT OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE-
PURSUANT TO STATUTE. THIS BILL
SPECIFIES THAT FIFTEEN MILLION
APPROPRIATED TO THE SAN JOAQUIN
RIVER CONSERVANCY SHALL BE
AVAILABLE FOR MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATIONS. AND LASTLY THIS
BILL MAKES TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING CHANGES TO VARIOUS
ITEMS IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT RELATED TO HIGHER
EDUCATION. AND ADULT EDUCATION
ISSUES- WE ARE HAPPY TO RESPOND
TO ANY MEMBERS QUESTIONS NOW.
ALL RIGHT LET'S SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY MEMBERS QUESTIONS LOOKS
LIKE SENATOR DOLLY. AND THEN
SENATOR NIELSEN WELL ACTUALLY
SENATOR NELSON PLEASE. YOU TAKE
PRECEDENT AS OUR VICE CHAIR GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND- I JUST. WHAT WE ARE BEING
PRESENTED WITH HERE TODAY ARE.
SOME POSITIVE DEVELOPMENTS I
WOULD CONSIDER THEM. IT IS A
BLESSING TO HAVE A YEAR WHERE
WE'RE NOT FACED WITH SUCH
ENORMOUS DEFICITS TO CONTEND
WITH. THERE IS ALSO A YEAR TO
BE WARY OF THE FUTURE. AS WE
HAVE THIS LEGISLATURE IN YEARS
PAST GOTTEN IN TROUBLE BY.
HAVING SURPLUSES OR EXTRA
REVENUE AND THEN SPENDING IT
AND BASE BUILDING WAYS THAT
APPLY JUST INTO THE FUTURE
WONDER IF TRYING REVENUES HIT
THE STATE THEN WE WERE IN BIG
TROUBLE. WELL THAT MAY BE
SOMETHING WE NEED TO BE WARY OF
I THINK WE SURELY MUST. AT AND
I THINK THAT THERE'S GOOD CAUSE
IN BOTH BILLS TO BE SUPPORTIVE.
BUT THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS. IN
THIS PARTICULAR ONE. THOSE OF
US AND THAT MEANS PROBABLY MOST
OF THE LEGISLATURE. WHO FACE
DANGER OF THE FIRES. I THINK
SHOULD BE WORRIED. A LOT OF
MONEY IN HERE UP TO HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS FROM OF WHICH
IS ALREADY THERE FRESH. BUT A
RECENT DEVELOPMENT GOOD CAUSE
FOR CONCERN. PUBLIC STATION.
GET A ANALYSIS OF PREVIOUS FIRE
PREVENTION FUNDS THAT WE HAD
ALLOCATED. WHEN IT CAME TO PASS
THAT THE FUNDS WERE NOT
EXPENDED. ACCORDING TO THE
ANALYSIS BY THE PUBLIC STATION.
CREATED QUITE A FUROR MOST
ASSUREDLY TO THOSE OF US WHO
FIERCELY LOST. IN THE LAST FIVE.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THE- VERY
ABLE AND LONG TERM YOU'RE.
DIRECTOR OF CAL FIRE I HAD TO
TAKE. IF YOU WILL THE HEAT. FOR
THIS. AND AS WE LOOK AT THIS
PARTICULAR BILL. IT REQUIRES
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
MAKE A DETERMINATION WHETHER
THAT NINETY EIGHT NEEDS TO BE
EXPANDED OR NOT. I WANT TO
ALLOW THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
THAT AUTHORITY. I WOULD RATHER
SEE THE LEGISLATURE PROSCRIBED.
AND THEN BE ABLE TO SEE- RECORD
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE PEOPLE.
TO HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THAT. SHOW WE DO NOT HAVE THE
SITUATION. THAT WE MOST
RECENTLY FACED. ADVISOR AND
PREVENTION EFFORTS. DO NOT NEED
TO BE THE BEST TIME IS NOT
DURING THE SUMMER OF THE WAR
MUCH. IF THE OTHER PART OF THE
YEAR. WHEN YOU CAN HARVEST OR
CLEAN OUT THAT FUEL WHAT DO THE
PREVENTIVE STAFF. IT'S ALSO
COMFORTING TO SOME OF US TO
KNOW THE LOCAL FIRE STRAIGHT
FOR FLORIDA YOU SHOULD FOR
EXAMPLE. THEY ARE LOCAL PEOPLE-
EXPEND THE MONEY IS VERY
RESPONSIBLE WAYS. AND I FEAR
THE RECORDING THE
ADMINISTRATION THE AUTHORITY WE
MAY SEE WHAT HAS BEEN PROPOSED
HERE IN THE PAST. BUILDING SOME
OF THAT MONEY OUT THE FIVE OH
ONE SEE THREE CORPORATIONS THAT.
I HAVE DIFFERENT IDEAS. ABOUT
WHAT MAINTAINING AND MANAGING
FORESTS AND WILDLANDS. THEY
ENTAIL. DOT THERE IS A DOWNSIDE.
AND I THINK THAT WE SHOULD. BE
CAUTIOUS ABOUT. LITTLE
EXPENDITURE HERE RELATED TO AN
ELECTION COMING UP TO THAT-
WE'VE GOT A RECOMPENSE THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS I UNDERSTAND
THAT. BUT IT ALSO DOES SPEAK TO
A LITTLE BIT OF MANIPULATION
FORTY FOUR TO A DISADVANTAGE.
AND THAT IS OF CONCERN AS WELL.
THAT SHARED THERE ARE OTHER
PROVISIONS THAT I'LL SPEAK TO
AS WE PROCEED. CHARTER SCHOOLS
WILL BE SOMETHING I DO WANT TO
TALK ABOUT IN THE FUTURE MADAM
CHAIRMAN. I AM GOING TO- LATELY
BUT IF THAT THANK. THANK YOU
BYE SURE NIELSEN US SENATOR ALI.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I DO HAVE
A QUESTION FOR ELLIE- SO WE THE
SENATOR FROM- WELL LET'S SEE.
FREMONT AND- THE I SAT ON THE
SIDE TO COMMITTEE AND WE DID
THE EARLY ACTION ITEM MONIES
FOR FIRE AND I WANTED TO KNOW-
HOW MUCH THAT MONEY HAS BEEN
CONTRACTED OUT AND WHAT
PROJECTS IT WAS IDENTIFIED TO
GO TO. L. A- CAN YOU ADDRESS
THAT OR IS THERE. YES I THINK
YOU UYS ENTERED ALL MY NAME IS
BRYAN BROWN I'M WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
YOU'RE RIGHT THERE WAS THE
EARLY ACTION PACKAGE FOR
WILDFIRE FUNDING THAT WAS
APPROVED BY THE LEGISLATURE
EARLIER THIS SPRING. WE DON'T
HAVE AN EXACT- BREAKDOWN RIGHT
NOW HOW MUCH IS CONTRACTED
VERSES. WORKING FOR IN HOUSE
STAFF I DON'T KNOW FINANCE MY
HOUSE SOME OF THAT INFORMATION.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION I'M
GONNA TURN IT OVER FOR SOME
MORE DETAILS TO- GEORGIA
ANGULAR. GOOD AFTERNOON SIR
DRIVE OVER THE BAR OF FINANCE-
SOME BOOKS I DON'T HAVE ANY
SPECIFIC DETAILS- TODAY ON THE
SPECIFIC ABOUT THAT BEEN
CONTRACTED TO DATE AND ONCE YOU
HAVE RECEIVED IT WE CAN
DEFINITELY- WORK WITH- WITH CAL
FIRE THE AGENCY DOES TO SEE-
KIND WHAT LEVEL DETAIL THEY
THEY COULD PROVIDE ON. THE FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX MILLION THAT
HAS ALREADY BEEN ADOPTED AS
PART OF EARLY ACTION EARLIER
THIS YEAR. THANK YOU THE LET ME
HELP YOU OUT WITH A LITTLE BIT-
THE SENATOR FROM SANTA CRUZ AND
I ASKED IN THE BUDGET HEARING.
IF WE COULD WE WANTED A
PERCENTAGE TO GO TO. FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS AND R. C. D.'S WHO
PEOPLE HAVE. SHOVEL READY JOBS
THE CONSERVANCY'S WHO ARE IN
THIS WORK ALL THE TIME SO I
WANT TO SHARE FIRST OF ALL IN
THIS BUDGET WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE. HALF A MILLION OR FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS I
BELIEVE PROPOSED AND I WANT TO
KNOW. I DON'T WORRY WE HAVE
CONTRACTORS READY TO WORK LET
ME GIVE AN EXAMPLE I JUST.
CALLED MY LOCAL THIS IS IN
BEAVER. OUR CD AND I ASKED THE
END THEY THEY WORK WITH THE
FIRE SAFE COUNCIL THEY WORK
WITH THE TRIBES THEY WORK WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THEY
WORK WITH ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES TO DO. PROJECTS SO THEY
DID GET SOME PROPER PROJECTS
FUNDED THEY HIT THEY GOT LIKE
FIVE OR SIX MILLION DOLLARS
WITH THE PROJECTS FUNDED BUT-
SHASTA COUNTY CROSSROADS FOREST
HEALTH NEEDS ANOTHER SEVEN
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND. NINE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
WELLINGTON FUEL BREAK FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND SOLDIER
MOUNTAIN WE ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION. SIX Q. COUNTY WHERE WE
HAVE THE LAB A FIRE GOING RIGHT
NOW. THE WILY RANCH PROJECT
THREE OR TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS.
THE CALDERA FOR SERVICE
PROJECTS SEVEN EIGHTY ONE MODOC
COUNTY HIGHWAY ONE THIRTY NINE
FUEL BREAK ONE AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS A TOTAL OF FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS OF PROJECTS
THAT ARE READY TO GO. TODAY
WITH LICE'S TIMBER OPERATOR'S
LICENSE FORSTER'S ALL THE
SEQUEL- EVERYTHING'S READY TO
GO SO I WANT TO KNOW. IN THIS
BUDGET ARE WE GONNA FUND THESE
PROJECTS THAT'S JUST ONE FIRE
SAFE COUNCIL. I REPRESENT
ELEVEN CARRIES I'M SURE IF I
HAD TIME TO GET TO ELDORADO
COUNTY. IN PLASTER THEY'RE ALL
IN THE SAME BOAT THERE'S PROFIT
SHOVEL READY PROJECTS MY
CONSERVANCY'S HERE ABOUT A
CONSERVANCY ALLOCATED THE FUNDS
AND THEY ALSO TOLD THE PHARMACY
CLOSES TO PARE BACK BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE THE MONEY.
THAT'S B. S. THE MONEY IS HERE
WE NEED TO GET IT TO THE
PEOPLE. THAT ARE READY TO SPEND
THE MONEY I'M I'M GONNA SUPPORT
THIS BILL BUT I WANT THE MONEY
TO GET TO THE GROUND. THE FOR
THE CAL FIRE FIREFIGHTERS ARE
FIGHTING FIRE RIGHT NOW THEY'RE
NOT DOING. MOVIE PROJECTS. WE
HAVE CONTRACTORS IN PEOPLE
READY TO DO IT LET'S PUT THE
MONEY IN AND DO IT AND QUIT.
RUNNING AROUND BACK AND FORTH
WHATEVER I'M TELLING YOU I'M
GONNA GET THE FULL LIST FROM MY
DISTRICT AND I'M GONNA KEEP
HAPPENING UNTIL WE- FIND THESE
PROJECTS. CALIFORNIANS DESERVE
BETTER. AND WE'RE NOT GETTING
IT THROUGH WHATEVER PROCESS IS
GOING ON HERE THE MONEY WAS IN
THE MONIES OUT WELL THERE'S
MONEY NEEDED AND THEY'RE READY
TO GO SO PLEASE. GET THE MONEY
TO THE GROUND. LET ME CALL ON
SENATOR LAYERED AND THEN
SENATOR Y. CASKEY IS YOUR IS
YOUR- MY COMPULSIVE SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE YES AND I THINK YOU
ARE GOING TO FINANCE IF YOU
WANT TO MAKE A RESPONSE HERE
YOU WANT WELL SINCE I WAS A
REFERRED TO BY MY ABLE AND
DISTINGUISHED COLLEAGUE FROM
BEAVER- I DID. IT AT THE
JANUARY BUDGET HEARING ASKED
THE FIRST QUESTION AND IT WAS
ALL OF THE FIRE MONEY THAT WAS
PROPOSED. WHAT PERCENT WOULD GO
LOCAL AND NOT TO STATE AGENCIES
AND ONCE WE GOT THE ANSWER BACK
OUT OF. THE HEARING. IT WAS 86%
AND I CAN'T SPEAK TO THE
ADDITIONAL MONEY THAT'S IN THIS
BILL BUT IF IT'S ANYWHERE NEAR
THAT. MY GOAL WAS THAT IT MEETS
EXACTLY THE GOALTHAT WAS
EXPRESSED BY THE SENATOR FROM
BEAVER. THAT IT'S NOT JUST
STATE AGENCIES THAT HAVE THE
SKILL AND ON OUR ON THE GROUND
AND THE ABILITY TO DO THIS. AND
WE HAVE THIS PROBLEM WHICH I AM
TRYING TO ADDRESS
LEGISLATIVELY. WHICH IS THAT
WHILE THE RESOURCES AGENCY IN
THE ADMINISTRATION MIGHT SAY
HERE'S OUR FIVE YEAR GOALS. ALL
WE SEE IS WHAT GOES IN THE
BUDGET IN ONE YEAR- A AND WE
DON'T SEE HOW IT ADDS TOGETHER
WHAT THE GOALS ARE WHAT IT DOES
OVER A FIVE YEAR TEN YEAR
PERIOD. AND SO. I HAVE A BUILD
OUT OF ASSEMBLY NATURAL
RESOURCES THIS MORNING
EVERYBODY ON THIS FLOOR VOTED
FOR. THAT BASICALLY SAYS WE'LL
TAKE THOSE GOALS. WILL PUT THEM
IN THE STATUTE OVER A FIVE YEAR
PERIOD BUT WE WILL ALSO. SET UP
A MECHANISM BY WHICH IN A
TRANSPARENT WAY WE MEASURE.
WHAT IS DONE AGAINST EACH OF
THOSE THOSE GOALS IF YOU HAVE A
BOWL. OF FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES TO BE TREATED WITH
PRESCRIBED FIRE. IT WILL
ACTUALLY. SAY THIS IS HOW MANY
ACRES WERE DONE IN A YEAR
THEY'LL SET UP. A WORKING GROUP
THAT WILL LOOK AT THIS AND SAY
WE'RE BETTER FIT TO DO THIS WE
SHOULD START TO MOVE INTO THIS
DIRECTION. AND SO. THAT MEANS
THAT THIS BUDGET ITEM IN FRONT
OF US HAS A CONTEXT. IT HAS A
CONTEXT BECAUSE IT'S PART OF
THOSE GOALS. IF IT IS TRUE TO
WHAT WAS SAID TO US OUT OF THE
HEARING IN THE FIRST HEARING A
LOT OF IT GOES LOCAL. AND THEN
IT'S MY HOPE THAT WE WILL BE
ABLE TO HAVE A MECHANISM TO
ACCURATELY MEASURE SO THAT IF
IT'S NOT GETTING TO CERTAIN-PLACES OR WE HAVE A GOAL OF
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES AND
SOMEHOW IT GOT TO A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND. WE HAVE A
SENSE OF WHAT WE'RE DOING AND
WHAT WE NEED TO DO AND HOW WE
ADJUST SO I THINK THAT THIS
BUDGET APPROPRIATION IS REALLY
APPROPRIATE. BUT BUT IT IS TRUE
THAT WE HAVE TO. PARSE IT
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WORK GOES
HOPE IT MEETS A LOT OF A LOCAL
NEEDS AND MEASURE IT AGAINST
THE GOALS SO THAT WE KNOW THAT
OVER TIME WE'RE DOING THE RIGHT
THING. THAT'S WHY I'M GOING TO-
WITH PLEASURE SUPPORT THIS BUT
THERE IS A LARGER CONTEXT.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALERT SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI. I DON'T
DISAGREE WITH ANYTHING INTO
TROUBLE MAN FROM THE COUNTY OF
TO HAMMER THE GENTLEMAN FROM
THE COUNTY OF LASSEN THE
GENTLEMAN FROM THE COUNTY OF
SANTA CRUZ HAS SAIDTHE
ARCHITECTURE THAT. WAS CREATED
WITH THE EARLY ACTION FIRE
ACTION WHICH INCLUDED A QUARTER
OF A MILLION MORE DOLLARS THAN
WHAT THE GOVERNOR HAD SAID THIS
SENATE. DESIGNED AT A EARLY
ACTION PLAN SO WE CAN GET MONEY
OUT THE DOOR FOR THE FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS BUT ALSO FOR THE PARKS
THERE IS NINETY THOUSAND NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS IN FOR PARK
DISTRICT WHICH MANAGE A LOT OF
LAND THAT SOME FORCE THE SAME.
THING WITH THE FISH AND
WILDLIFE SERVICE WE HAVEN'T
DONE A GOOD JOB OF GIVING MONEY
TO THE FISH AND WILDLIFE
SERVICE WE SPECIFICALLY IN THE
EARLY ACTION PLAN PUT IN MONEY
FOR THE CONSERVANCY'S WE NAME
THE CONSERVANCY'S AND SAID WE
WANT THIS. EARLY ACTION
WILDFIRE MONEY TO BE SPENT
BECAUSE WE WERE IN MARCH AND
WE'RE HOPING TO GET. AND WE
DIDN'T ALWAYS GIVE YOUR TRUCK
HERE AND I WAS GONNA BE THE
FIRE SEASON WAS GONNA START SO
EARLY. FOR THAT MARKET WAS
THERE WHEN THE COMMITTEE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE IN THE THIS
COMMITTEE ON THE WHOLE ARE THE
ACTION THAT WE TOOK WAS FOR A
FIVE YEAR PLAN. WE ARE
RECOMMENDATION FROM SUB TWO WAS
FOR A FIVE BILLION DOLLAR FIVE
YEAR PLAN SO THERE WAS A HALF A
BILLION. EARLY ACTION IN AND
OUT THIS YEAR IT WAS FOR FIVE
BILLION THIS. THE FIRST ACTION
THAT WE TOOK ON A BUDGET
DELAYED SOME OF THAT MONEY IT
WAS ONLY THERE WAS. TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THOUSAND OR THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS EXTRA
SO THIS THIS FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION BRINGS US BACK UP TO
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THAT
THAT THE SENATE HAS TAKEN SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT. NEARLY ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
FIRE PREVENTION BEINGS SPENT.
YES FOR COMPARISON THE PEOPLE
WHO DR LAURA WHO'S WRITTEN ON
THIS AND ADVISE THAT THE SCENT
THEY'RE TALKING A TEN YEAR
INVESTMENT AT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR. FOR WE'RE STILL
SHORT. IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT SOME
OF TE SCIENTISTS ARE SAYING
THAT WHAT WE NEED BUT THE- BUT
THE ARCHITECTURE WAS TO GIVE
THESE FIRE SAFE COUNCILS THEIR
MONEY IN. I SUPPORT I HOPE
EVERYBODY GOES BACK TO THEIR
DISTRICTS AND FINDS OUT THE
LOCAL MONEY THAT THAT WE SHOULD
USE AND HOW MUCH MORE THAT THEY
THEY GOT BUT THAT'S- THAT'S THE
IDEA IS. AND I'M CONCERNED THAT
FINANCE HAVING THE FILE- TAKE
THEIR STUFF LIKE THAT BUT WHAT
IT'S SAYING IS THAT IN THIS
BUDGET YEAR. IF WE CAN FIND
FOLKS TO DO THE WORK AND TO GET
SOME OF THE FUEL CELL. THERE'S
MONEY IN THE SENATE BILL AGAIN.
THE FINAL FINAL HASN'T BEEN. I
ENTERED WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE N. N. THE ASSEMBLY ON
HOW EACH OF THE CATEGORIES WE-
HAVE RECOMMENDED THAT ALL
THESE. YOU KNOW WE HAVE MONEY
FOR BIOMASS WORD FOR
TRANSPORTATION OF GET SOME OF
THE FUEL OUT OF THE FORCE SO.
IT'S A BEAR AND THIS. FOR THE
CONSERVANCY'S IN THE AGENCIES
AND THE LOCAL DISTRICTS THAT
THAT HAVE THE NEED THE DESIRES
THAT WE GET IT OUT IMMEDIATELY
AND I SEE IMMEDIATELY MEMBER
THE FISCAL YEAR JUST STARTED SO
SOME OF THIS MONEY MAY THE
PLANNING DOLLARS WILL BE OUT IN
NOVEMBER AND DECEMBER SO THE
WORK INDEED BE DONE AS SOON AS
THE- AREAS- PREVAILED PULL FOR
THAT SO THAT'S THE IDEA AND
THEN WE COME BACK NEXT. NEXT
YEAR AND YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT
THAT I WILL RE UP THE FIVE YEAR
PLAN SO THAT WE CAN DO THIS SO
ALL THE PLAYERS. IT THEY'RE
DOING FIRE PREVENTION KNOW THAT
THIS IS NOT ONE AND DONE THAT
WE'RE LOOKING LONG TERM. WHAT
THAT OCCURRED TO HAVE A- THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DID
YOU WANT TO ADD ANYTHING. YES
THANK YOU THANK YOU- SENATORS
FOR YOUR QUESTIONS AND YOUR
COMMENTS I JUST WANT TO
UNDERSCORE THE FACT THAT THERE
IS ONE POINT CLOSE TO ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS INCLUDED
IN THIS BUDGET BILL WHICH DOES
INCLUDE THE FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY
SIX MILLION FOR EARLY ACTION-
B. AND THEN AN ADDITIONAL FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT MILLION
THAT WAS THAT INCLUDES TWO
HUNDRED MILLION. THEY DID R. F.
FINDS. THEIR GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND IN THE CURRENT
YEAR SORRY IN THE BUDGET YEAR
AND THEN AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION THAT WAS
PROGRAMMED INTO BITE YOUR PLUS
ONE AND THAT FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION. IS WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING IS BEING ACCELERATED
INTO THE BUDGET YEAR- SHOULD
THE NEED ARISE AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS IN REGARDS TO
THE NUMBER OF LOCAL PROJECTS
THAT- ARE. ARE ARE READY TO GO-
REALLY JUST AS- THE IDEA WAS TO
FACE IT BECAUSE- SORT OF
OPERATIONAL ICING IT BUT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT IF THERE IS A
NEED IN THE IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
THAT WE WANT TO MAKE THOSE
FUNDS AVAILABLE SO AGAIN CLOSE
TO ONE POINT FIVE BILLION. FOR
WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND THAT IS
A SUBSET OF THE TWO POINT TWO
BILLION- THAT'S PART OF A
LARGER WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND
ALL HAZARD EMERGENCY RESPONSE-
THAT'S INCLUDED IN THIS BUDGET
BILL SO AGAIN UNDERSCORING THAT
THERE THERE ARE DOLLARS
AVAILABLE- AND THEN WE WILL THE
STATE DEPARTMENTS WILL BE
WORKING WITH LOCALS. TO FUND
THOSE- LOCAL PROJECTS. THANK
YOU. SENATOR MENENDEZ THANK YOU
SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR- I YOU KNOW
I THINK THE SENATORS WHO SPOKE
BEFORE ME- DID A FINE JOB OF
POINTING OUT SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WE ALL HAVE WITH
THIS BILL RELATING TO FIRE
SAFETY AND I WOULD REALLY LIKE
FOR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
DIG A LITTLE DEEPER ON THIS I
KNOW SHE WAS JUST ON- BUT- IF.
IF FINANCE IS GOING TO BE THE
ULTIMATE ARBITER OF WHETHER OR
NOT THESE FUNDS ARE ALLOCATED
THEN I THINK. THERE'S SOME
QUESTIONS THAT NEED TO BE
ANSWERED WITH RESPECT TO THE
PROJECTS THAT ARE READY TO GO
IN DISTRICTS THAT STILL HAVEN'T
BEEN FUNDED AND THAT. INCLUDES
PROJECTS IN MY DISTRICT IN
PROBABLY IN MANY OF THE MEMBERS
DISTRICTS IN THIS COMMITTEE
HEARING- YOU KNOW I THINK THE
PEOPLE ARE THERE WHO ARE READY
AND WILLING AND ABLE TO. WORK
ON THESE JOBS IN THE FUNDING IS
SUPPOSED TO BE THERE BUT WE
HAVEN'T RECEIVED THE FIGHTING I
KNOW. DEPARTMENT FINANCES SAID
IN THE PAST THAT. THE FINDING
WAS IT NEEDED BECAUSE THERE IS
A BOTTLENECK. OF FINDING
ALREADY BUT MEANWHILE WE ARE IN
OUR DISTRICTS YOU KNOW BEGGING
FOR THIS MONEY. TO GET THESE
PROJECTS DONE MAKE SURE
COMMUNITIES ARE SAFE IN THE
MONEY ISN'T TRICKLING DOWN TO
OUR LEVEL AND GETTING THESE
PROJECTS DONE SO IF YOU.
WOULDN'T MIND- ALLOWING THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO TALK
ABOUT. HOW WE'RE GONNA MAKE
SURE THATTHIS MONEY DOES GET
TO WHERE IT IS NEEDED I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. YOU'RE WELCOME
DEPARTMENT FINANCE YEAH THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION CENTER
MELINDA'S I WILL TURN OVER IT-
TO MY- COLLEAGUE SERGIO ANGULAR
FOR THE DETAILS. HEY CANCER
DRIVER PART OF FINANCE SO I
THINK I'LL JUST GO TO A COUPLE
THINGS I THINK AS A- THE TREND.
THAT THEY CATEGORIZE ATION OF
HOW THE MONEY WOULD BE SPENT-
ACTUALLY HASN'T BEEN DECIDED
YET SO THAT'S GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT AS PART OF. OUR
SUMMER DISCUSSION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE WILL ACTUALLY BE
DETERMINING- PROGRAMMATIC LEE-
KIND OF HARD TO CATEGORICALLY
SPEND THE DIFFERENT FUNDING
THAT IS ALLOCATED FOR. THE
BUDGET YEAR AND THEN THE TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE FUNDING THAT
AND THIS BILL WE'RE PROPOSING
TO ACCELERATE. SO ONCE- THOSE
CATEGORIES ARE ARE DECIDED. BY
THAT. IS THE BUDGET YOU'RE
FUNNY THAT WE WOULD INCLUDE A
DEFINITE KIND OF FOCUSING ON ON
KIND OF HIGH PRIORITY OF FIRE
AREAS AND TO EXTEND THOSE
DOLLARS ARE GETTING OUT
QUICKLY. AND THEN THERE'S A
NEED TO AUTHORIZE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO BE SPENT IN THE
BUDGET YEAR THAT'S WHEN WE
WOULD TRIGGER THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THOSE SPECIFIC
CATEGORIES. THAT WILL BE
DECIDED- ULTIMATELY OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE MONTHS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. SENATOR DOLE YOU
RIDE YOUR BIKE A- SENATOR
MELINDA SHE WANT TO FOLLOW UP
ON THE QUESTION GO AHEAD I DO I
JUST HAVE A FOLLOW UP THANK
YOU- MY APOLOGY SENATOR DOLLY
BUT I JUST. WANT TO FOLLOW UP
ON THAT BECAUSE- I. I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS WHEN. IS THIS GOING
TO HAPPEN WHEN THE NEED IS
THERE NO WORD ENTIRE CITIES ARE
PRACTICALLY EMPIRE SEASON. YEAR
ROUND SO. TO BE GIVEN AN
EXPLANATION THAT WE'RE WORKING
ON- THE MECHANICS OF THIS IS.
FRIGHTENING TO SOME OF US WHO
HAVE AREAS OF OUR DISTRICT ARE
EXTREMELY- HI FIRES AND SO. E
COULD YOU PERHAPS ADDRESS THAT
BECAUSE THE- THE TIME LINE I
MEAN THE TIME IS NOW IN THE
TIME LINE TO ME SEEMS. REALLY
STRETCHED OUT. YEAH SO IN TERMS
OF FUNDING AVAILABLE NOW SO THE
FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
ADOPTED AS PART OF EARLY
ACTION. THAT'S SOMETHING
CURRENTLY THE DEPARTMENTS THAT
WERE PART OF THAT- WALL FIRE
PREVENTION OF COURSE REALLY
IT'S LAND ARE CURRENTLY WORKING
ON ALLOCATING. AND NOW THE
DIVISIONAL FUNDS THAT ARE IN
THIS BUDGET. SO THOSE AREN'T
AVAILABLE UNTIL WE DO WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE TO PROGRAMMATIC
WE ALLOCATE. BUT THERE IS AN
EXISTING DOLLAR AMOUNT TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
APPROVED EARLIER THIS YEAR AND
THAT CURRENTLY IS- BEING BEING
ALLOCATEDACROSS THE DIFFERENT
PROJECTS. THAT ALIGN WITH THE
CATEGORIES THAT WERE APPROVED
BY THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR. SENATOR ALI. THANK
YOU FOR INDULGING ME- SO THE
QUESTION TO ME IS FOR ME THEN.
WITH THIS ADDITIONAL FUNDS. IF
LET'S SY FOR EXISTENCE CAL
FIRE CAN'T WHICH WE'VE HEARD I
MEAN THAT THEY THEY DON'T HAVE
THE RESEARCH DIDN'T HAVE THE
PERSONNEL TO GET TO THE MONEY
OUT. IF THAT'S THE CASE THESE
EXTRA FUNDS HOW DO WE GET THOSE
RESOURCES TO. THE SIERRA NEVADA
CONSERVANCY WHO HAS THE PEOPLE
TO EXPAND THE MONEY TO THE FIRE
SAFE COUNCILS TO THE R. C.
D.'S. WHAT'S THE PROCESS THAT
THIS THIS BUDGET COMMITTEE
NEEDS TO TAKE ACTION TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU HAVE THE ABILITY
TO MOVE THAT MONEY TO PLACES
WHERE WE CAN SPEND. YES I JUST
LOOK AT THE EXAMPLE OF THE
EARLY ACTION SO I WILL NOTED
EARLIER THE EARLY ACTION DID
INCLUDE SPECIFIC FUNDING CALL
FOR CONSERVANCIES- THAT DID
ALLOCATE. HOURS ARE BEGINNING
TO TELL YOU THAT WHEN YOU. AND
SO WHEN WE ALLOCATE THE
FUNDING- THAT IS INCLUDED IN
THIS BUDGET WILL REFLECT THAT
YOUR DIRECT PROGRAMMATIC LEE
CATEGORIZED ALLOCATE THE
FUNDING. TO THE EXTENT THERE IS
A SPECIFIC CONSERVANCY-
OCCASION JUST LIKE THERE WAS IN
IN THE EARLY ACTION I THINK
THAT'S WHAT WOULD BE THE KIND
OF. THOUGHT THAT THAT WOULD GO
TOWARDS A DIFFERENT PROJECTS
BUT THOSE DETAILS I THINK ON
THE FUNDING IN THIS SPECIFIC
BUDGET- THAT WE'RE DISCUSSING
TODAY THAT'S WHAT WOULD BE
DISCUSSED- YOU KNOW OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE MONTHS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. BUT THE BY THIRTY
SIX MILLION THAT WAS IN EARLY
ACTION. IT ACTUALLY INCLUDES
FUNDING FOR CONSERVANCY
SPECIFICALLY TO GET THOSE
PROJECTS ON GROUND. RIGHT I
UNDERSTAND THAT. I UNDERSTAND
IT WE ALLOCATED I SAID ON SEPT
TWO. I UNDERSTAND THAT WE
ALLOCATED THE RESOURCES TO
THOSE CONSERVANCY'S. AND TO MY
KNOWLEDGE THEY'VE USED THAT
MONEY. WE NEED TO REPLENISH
THAT NOW WITH THIS POT. IS IT
WORTH IT FOR THE FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN TWENTY FIVE YEARS THAT
I'VE BEEN ELECTED. WE'RE ALWAYS
USUALLY TRYING TO FIND MONEY.
AND FOR THE FIRST TIME WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
SPEND IT. IT'S UNBELIEVABLE TO
ME THAT WE CAN'T. FIGURE OUT
THAT. THE CONSERVATIVES KNOW
HOW TO SPEND IT THE R. C. D.'S
NOT TO SPEND IT BUT CAL FIRE IS
BUSY FIGHTING FIRE RIGHT NOW
THEY DON'T HAVE THE- RESOURCES
OR THEY DON'T HAVE THE KNOW
HOW. TO GET THIS MONEY OUT TO
THE GROUND SO MY QUESTION TO
YOU. IS I KNOW WE DIDN'T HEAR
ANY ACTION I SAID ON THE- SUB
TO COMMITTEE WHEN WE ALLOCATED
THE RESOURCES. I WANT TO KNOW
HOW TO TAKE THESE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCE WE'RE GONNA VOTE ON
TODAY. AND GET THEM TO THE
PLACES THAT KNOW HOW TO SPEND
MONEY. THEN PROJECTS ARE
AVAILABLE. IT IT MAYBE I'M
TALKING TO THE WRONG PEOPLE BUT
I DON'T HAVE AN ACT I DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND ADMINISTRATION TO
GET IT DONE BUT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE GET THESE PROJECTS
DONE IT'S RIDICULOUS THAT WE
HAVE THIS MONEY AND WE CAN'T
GET IT TO THE GROUND. SO WHAT'S
THE PROCESS. SO FOR THESE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. THERE
WILL BE ADDITIONAL DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE LEGISLATURE OVER THIS
SUMMER. MEDICALLY ALLOCATE THAT
FUNDING AND SO AS PART OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AND A FUTURE BUDGET
BUILDING HERE THAT WAS AN
APPROPRIATE THOSE DOLLARS
THAT'S WHEN WE WOULD CATEGORIZE
DOLLARS AND SIX AND THERE'S
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO GET
CATEGORIZED FOR THE
CONSERVANCY'S. AND THAT'S WHERE
THAT FUNDING WOULD BE AVAILABLE.
THANK YOU ON MY OWN TIME I MAY
SUGGEST INTO THIS. BUDGET
COMMITTEE. THAT WE FIGURE OUT
NOT THROUGH THE SUMMER WE HAVE
FIRES GOING ON WE HAVE
PROJECTS. I'VE IDENTIFIED THE
NEED FINDING HOW WE CAN GET
THAT DONE SOONER THAN LATER SO
I'LL DEFER TO. THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN THOSE NEGOTIATIONS BUT I
WILL BE WATCHING THIS AND I
WILL BRING YOU A LIST OF
PROJECTS CONTINUALLY. AND AS
ONE THING AS A AS A- MAYBE RARE
BUT I ACTUALLY FOLLOW UP AND
GET IN THE WEEDS AND GO TO THE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT THEY NEED AND THIS IS
A NEED THAT THEY NEED. THIS
WOULD WILL HELP NOT JUST MY
DISTRICT WILL HELP A LOT OF
COMPANY THERE'S- AND THERE'S
THE PARKS THERE'S ALL THESE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE PROJECTS READY
AND WE SHOULD FIND THEM. NOT
THIS FALL BUT RIGHT NOW SO. WE
CAN GET IT DONE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. YOU'RE WELCOME
SENATOR DOLLY SENATOR NIELSEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THESE
BILLS WERE REFERRED TO THE
LEGISLATURE NOW APPROPRIATING.
BY THE STATUTE. BUT THE MONEY.
WILL BE DETERMINED TO THE
DEGREE THAT IT GOES OUT. BUT I
UNDERSTAND IT BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THE WEATHER OR NOT.
WHICH WOULD INPUT NOT ON FIRE
BUT IT IT SPECIFICALLY EMPOWERS
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THAT
WELL WE'RE NOT GOING TO SPEND
THAT MONEY RIGHT NOW. WE'LL
SPEND IT SOME OTHER TIME. I
FEEL RELUCTANT. TO GIVE OUT
THAT AUTHORITY TO THEM TO DO SO.
BECAUSE FRANKLY THERE'S THE
ELEMENT OF TRUST HERE. AND WE
HAVE BECAUSE NOT TO BE TRUSTED.
I WOULD LIKE TO DIRECTLY ASK
FINANCE WHAT IS GOING TO BE
YOUR CRITERIA WHAT ARE YOUR
BENCHMARKS TO APPROVE
ADDITIONAL MONEY. TO GO OUT TO
THAT UP TO A BILLION DOLLARS.
WHAT IS YOUR CRITERIA NOW YOU
TALK ABOUT TALKING TO THE
LEGISLATURE. AND WE KNOW WHO
THAT NEW AGE. IT ALSO TALKS
ABOUT REPORTING. TO THE
LEGISLATURE. WHICH IS. THAT'S
THE LEAST EFFECTIVE THING WE
GET AROUND TO IT SOMETIME AND
SAY HEY THIS IS WHAT WE DECIDED
TO DO. AFTER THE FACT. COULD BE
WELL AFTER WE ADJOURN WE HAVE
NO ABILITY TO. THE PRESSURE ON
THE DEPARTMENT TO SPEND ALL THE
AGENCY. TO SPEND. PHIL AS WE
CONTEMPLATE THIS AUTHORITY
BEING ACCORDED TO FINANCE TO
MAKE A DETERMINATION OF HOW
MUCH OF THE MONEY. WILL BE
APPORTIONED AND PERCENT OUT.
WHAT IS YOUR CRITERIA I'M
SENATOR NELSON IF I CAN
INTERJECT THIS- THE BILL BEFORE
US DOES NOT GIVE THEM THE-
CARTE BLANCHE AUTHORITY. RATHER
IT IS A BUDGET BILL JUNIOR THAT-
PREACHED THE FINDING AND AS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE'S
EXPLAINED. WE ARE WE WILL TAKE
A SUBSEQUENT ACTION THAT
DETAILS OUT HOW THE SPENDING IS
AS WE DID IN THE EARLY ACTION
ON THE FIRST SET OF FUNDS SO- I
EXPECT THAT WE WILL BE TAKING
ACTION MEANING THE LEGISLATURE
TO DIRECT THESE THE DIFFERENT
PARTS AS WE HAVE IN THE PAST
AND WHAT I HEAR FROM THE
VARIOUS COMMENTS. OF THE
MEMBERS HAVE SPOKEN IS THAT
THEY'RE HOPING THAT WE WOULD DO
THAT- WE WOULD EXPEDITE THAT
PROCESS. SHOW THIS IS SUBJECT
DOWN TO THE APPROVAL BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO STATUTE. PERHAPS
CANNOT MAKE ITS OWN UNILATERAL
DECISION SAY WELL WE'RE ONLY
GOING TO SPEND TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION. THEY HAVE TO
COME TO THE LEGISLATURE AND GET
OUR APPROVAL. FOR THE SPECIFIC
PROJECTS AND THEN THE MONEY
WILL GO OUT YOU WILL TAKE AS I
INDICATED THE SUBSEQUENT ACTION
WHICH DETAILS OUT THE FUNDING
BUCKETS FOR THIS MONEY AS WE
DID IN THE EARLY ACTION. WELL
I'LL JUST ECHO MY COLLEAGUES'
COMMENTS SHOULD THE
ADMINISTRATION SHOULD BE
ADVISED MANY OF US ARE GONNA BE
WATCHING THIS VERY CAREFULLY.
AND WILL BE VERY VOCAL ABOUT IT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE MONEY
DOES GET TO THE PARTIES IN THE
AREAS MOST AFFECTED. AND ENOUGH
DEFECTIVE USE OF THOSE DOLLARS
WE DON'T WANT TO BE AROUND HERE
NEXT YEAR SAYING OH GEE WE'VE
GOT SOME MORE MONEY THAT WE
DIDN'T SPEND LAST YEAR. THANK
YOU. CERTAINLY ALL RIGHT LET'S
SEE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON US SENATOR STERN GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
HOPE THE PUBLIC CAN ADD ONE BIT
OF VALUE I THINK IT COLLOQUY IS
BEEN. VERY USEFUL THUS FAR AND
I APPRECIATE THE URGENCY OF
FROM SUCH A DIVERSE- GROUP OF
MEMBERS FROM ALL OVER THE STATE
IN SUCH DIFFERENT REGIONS- THE
URGENCY AND THE NEED- IN
WILDFIRE SPENDING IN REALLY
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR-
PUTTING FORWARD THIS FRAMEWORK
AND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I
JUST WANT TO GET. ONE POINT OF
CLARIFICATION ON THE RECORD
WHAT I HEARD DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SAY. IS THAT. REGIONAL
DEMONSTRATIONS OF NEAT. THE
ABILITY SORT OF IN THIS INTERIM
PROCESS FOR THE LOCALS TO COME
BACK AND DEMONSTRATE TO US INTO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THEIR
NEED I WILL BE IN IN A CRITICAL
FACTOR IN DETERMINING- THE
FUTURE ALLOCATION STRATEGY DID
I DID I HEAR THAT. CORRECTLY.
TO OUR FRIENDS AT FINANCE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THIRD
DRIVE OUR CAR FINANCE- I THINK
IT'S KIND OF AT A HIGH LEVEL
JUST SUFFERED FROM THE CONTEXT
TO. BUT IT'S BASED OFF OF THE
WILDFIRE AND FOREST RESILIENCE
ACTION PLAN AND ONE OF THE
COMPONENTS THAT ARE HIGHLIGHTED
AS PART OF THAT STRATEGY IS
CALLING FOR GOALS TO BE.
ACHIEVED LARGELY THROUGH
REGIONAL STRATEGY THA SO THAT
IS DEFINITELY ONE OF THE
CATERPILLARS AND COMPONENT THAT
WAS IDENTIFIED IN THE PLAN
WHICH WAS THE BASIS FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION- INITIAL WALL
WALLS ARE VENTURES AND- SO IT
IS DEFINITELY ONE OF THE
CRITERIA. I APPRECIATE THAT AND
I WOULD JUST SAY I THINK THAT
GIVES US ALL REALLY IMPORTANT
HOMEWORK TO DO OVER THIS RECESS
TO TAKE INVENTORY TO WORK WITH
OUR LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS AND SAY.
WHAT IS THAT NEED PUTTING
PROPOSALS AND REAL INTEGRATED
PROJECTS TOGETHER AT SCALE NOT
JUST ONE OFF. PROJECTS HERE AND
THERE BUT COMPREHENSIVE REGION
SCALE AND- I KNOW IN OUR REGION
DOWN IN LOS ANGELES AND HER
COUNTIES WE'VE ALREADY. I SPENT
DOWN ALL THE FUNDING HAS BEEN
ALLOCATED FROM THE EARLY ACTION
BUDGET SO I THINK THE NEED IS
THERE BUT- I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND ALL OF THE LEADERSHIP HERE
TO. TO REALLY ADD SOME MEAT ON
THE BONES AND TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THOSE LOCAL AND REGIONAL
ARCHITECTURES TODAY. TO GET
MONEY OUT THE DOOR TO KEEP
PEOPLE SAFE ESPECIALLY THOSE
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES SO
SINCERELY PROJECT MANAGER.
THANK YOU. OKAY I DON'T THINK I
SEE ANY OTHER MIKES UP. THIS IS
ON THE- BUDGET ACTIVE A BUDGET
BILL JUNIOR- SO WE WILL MOVE TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
PRESENTATION ON AB ONE THIRTY
WHICH IS OUR EDUCATION BILL-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR ERIC FULLY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- AND
PRESENTING AN AB ONE THIRTY THE
K. TWELVE EDUCATION HEATHER
BELL AMONG THE PROVISIONS OF AB
ONE THIRTY THAT'S STILL RETIRED
FROM FLEA ELEVEN BILLION IN K.
TWELVE EDUCATION BUDGET
DEFERRALS AND APPROPRIATES
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT EIGHT
BILLION A PROP PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR A
COMBINED TOTAL OF THREE
BILLION. TO EXPAND THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND USE OF THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOL MODEL TO ALL
SCHOOLS IN COMMUNITIES WITH
HIGH LEVELS OF POVERTY AND
ALLOCATES ONE POINT ONE BILLION
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND TO INCREASE- THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
CONCENTRATION BRANCH FROM 5265%
OF THE LCF BASED GRANTS TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
SPECIFIED ADULTS PROVIDING
DIRECT SERVICES TO STUDENTS. ON
SCHOOL CAMPUSES AND APPROPRIATE
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THREE
MILLION AT ONETIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR
COMBINED INITIAL TOTAL OF
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION TO SUPPORT A MULTI YEAR
PLAN TO ESTABLISH THE EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM-
THIS WOULD PROVIDE EXPANDED DAY
FULL YEAR INSTRUCTION AND
ENRICHMENT FOR ALL ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL STUDENTS WITH A
PARTICULAR FOCUS ON LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES AT THE
HIGHEST CONCENTRATIONS OF LOW
INCOME STUDENTS. ARE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE. I'M BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE IT
INCREMENTALLY ESTABLISHES
UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN WITH FULL
IMPLEMENTATION ANTICIPATED BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX-
IT REQUIRES SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
IS TO PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH AN
INDEPENDENT STUDY OPTION-
PREDICATEDUPON THE INCLUSION
OF A SERIES OF IMPROVEMENTS TO
THE STATE'S EXISTING
INDEPENDENT STUDY PROGRAM. IT
APPROPRIATES THREE HUNDRED
MILLION PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO ESTABLISH
A CALIFORNIA PRE KINDERGARTEN
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION
GRANT PROGRAM. RIGHT AT LEAST
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
PRESCHOOL OR TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS. IT
OPERATES FOUR HUNDRED NINETEEN
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR A GRANT PROGRAM TO SUPPORT
THE CONSTRUCTION OR
REHABILITATION OF CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM.
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN AND
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
FACILITIES- INTERPRETS TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT GRANTS
FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION AND
MODERNIZATION PROJECT PROJECTS
UNDER THE SCHOOL FACILITIES
PROGRAM- IT APPROPRIATES ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT THE
EDUCATOR EFFECTIVENESS BLOCK
GRANTS. AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST
THE BILL REQUIRES ALL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE- TO PROVIDE TWO
FREE MEALS PER DAY TO ANY
STUDENT WHO REQUEST A MEAL
REGARDLESS OF. INCOME
ELIGIBILITY. I'M HAPPY TO
RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE MEMBERS. I HEARD QUESTIONS
ON THIS ONE- I SEE SENATOR
NIELSEN'S MIKE UP SENATOR
NIELSEN. SENATOR NELSON. YES
MADAM CHAIR THE. THE DAY AFTER
SCHOOL FOR THEM SPECIAL ED. BUT
YOU'RE NOT GETTING AHEAD OF
MYSELF IF. THE CONCERN I HAVE.
SPEAKING TO THE PLUS THE PROCS.
THE DEBT TO THE SCHOOLS IS
NECESSARY THE SPECIAL ED CAREER
TECH. THE ASSISTANCE FOR
RECRUITING AND DEVELOPING OUR
TEACHERS WHICH WE ALWAYS NEED
TO DO MORE OF. THESE ARE PLUSES.
BUT I HAVE SOME CONCERNS. ABOUT
HOW WE'RE GOING TO BE DEALING
WITH THE CHARTER SCHOOLS.
CALIFORNIA. DANISH CHARTER
SCHOOLS. AND THEN A LIFESAVER.
TO MANY OF OUR STUDENTS. BUT
TYPICALLY IN THE DISADVANTAGES
OF DESTRUCTION. YOUR PARENTS
HAVE SOUGHT THIS BETTER
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
WHERE THE K. TWELVE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS LET THEM DOWN. THERE'S
GOING TO BE A PARENT MISSION
STUDYING OF THIS AND I WOULD
HOPE THAT THAT. STUDYING. BEAR
FRUIT. AND THAT THE CONTINUED
ATTACKS. ON CHARTER SCHOOLS.
DOES NOT CONTINUE IN THIS
BUDGET. THE FETTERS THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN PUT ON OUR CHARTER
SCHOOLS. THAT ENSURE THAT THEY
WOULD REMAIN AS MEDIOCRE. AS
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS. THAT'S BEEN
A LONG TIME. ATTEMPT AND IT IS
NOT AT ALL IN THE BEST INTEREST.
OF OUR STUDENTS. PHIL I TAKE
THE IN THIS PARTICULAR AREA.
THE JURY MUST BE OUT. AND WHICH
MUST MONITOR. AND KEEP AN EYE
ON THE. AND I RETAIN SOME
CONCERN. ABOUT THE. IF YOU WILL.
LEVELING DOWN. A TEACHER
COMPETENCE AND ABILITY- PRETTY
MUCH DIMINISHED THE CASH THE-
HAVE BEEN VERY IMPORTANT OVER
THE YEARS TO MAINTAIN. TEACHERS
ABILITY AND COMPETENCE. NOW WE
HAVE A B. GRADE STANDARD. DID
YOU GET A B. GRADE THAT ****
YOU QUALIFIED. I'M NOT SO SURE.
IT DOES THAT IS A SUFFICIENT
MEASURE. FOR OUR TEACHERS. I'M
MAKING THIS OBSERVATION
RHETORICALLY BUT IT IS ONE THAT
I THINK THE PUBLIC. SHOULD PAY
HEED AND ATTENTION TO. WE ARE
FAILING MISERABLY AND HAVE FOR
DECADES IN MATH. EVEN SCIENCE
THE THIRTY NINTH. IN ENGLISH.
AND WE'RE PUTTING CHILDREN OUT
INTO THE COMMUNITIES. I'M NOT
EQUIPPED WITH THOSE LIFE SAVING
TOOLS. AND WE DO NOT HAVE FISH
AND FISH ON THAT CAPABILITY TO
THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF EDUCATION
TO PROVIDE FOR OUR TEACHERS AND
THEN ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN DEMONSTRATED THAT
COMPETENCY THOSE TEACHERS.
WE'RE DOING A DISSERVICE. I PUT
THIS OUT OF A BIT OF A WATCH. A
RED FLAG FOR THE FUTURE. BUT WE
SHOULD ALWAYS TREAT FOR OUR
STUDENTS THE LEVEL OF EDUCATION
NOT LEVEL DOWN. OR PUT A CAP ON
IT BE THERE TO BE. OR SHE GREAT.
LET ME CLOSE WITH A STORY. WHEN
OUR OLDEST SON WAS. GETTING
READY ALL MY OTHER CHILDREN
GOING THROUGH PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
BUT WHAT I CALL THE SECOND CROP.
WHEN THE OLDEST WITH
APPROACHING THE TIME TO ENROLL
IN SCHOOL. TO DECIDE WHETHER
THEY WENT TO PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE
PRIVATE NOTION FIRST TIME WE'D
EVER CONSIDERED PRIVATE. I WENT
TO A PUBLIC MEETING. OR IN THAT
DISTRICT WAS AN ENTERTAINING
SOMETHING CALLED OUTCOME BASED
EDUCATION. I WAS CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT. ALCON BASED
EDUCATION. WHAT IT WOULD MEAN
THE DIRECT TEACHER CONTACT WITH
OUR STUDENTS. AMONG OTHER
THINGS. BUT THEN ONE OF THE
TEACHERS GOT UP. AND BRAG. THE
DISTRICT WAS GOING TO ADOPT A
POLICY THAT THERE WOULD BE NO
GRADE LESS THAN THREE. IN THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICT. WITH OUR
CHILDREN. I WAS IRATE AND I
ROSE AND I SHED WE OWE IT TO
OUR CHILDREN. THAT THEY MAY
FAIL. BECAUSE WHAT DO YOU LEARN.
IF EVERYBODY GETS A TROPHY IF
EVERYBODY GETS TO SEE. IS THAT
THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
EXPECTATION. THAT WE HAVE FOR
OUR STUDENTS THE STREET. AND
WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT BY THAT
DECISION. I SEE THAT JUST KIND
OF HOVERING IN THE BACKGROUND
HERE WE SHOULD EVER BE WORRIED
AND WARY OF LETTING THAT HAPPEN
FURTHER. IN OUR K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS. LET ME SEE IF THERE'S
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
BUT SENATOR MELINDA IS. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- SO I HAVE A
QUESTION ABOUT THE- FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS- BUILD.
ALLOCATED FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION- OF ETHNIC
STUDIES IN OUR SCHOOL IT'S
BASED ON THE PASSAGE OF AB ONE
A ONE A BILL WHICH IS STILL
WINDING ITS WAY THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE HAS NOT BEEN SIGNED
BY THE GOVERNOR IN EIGHTY ONE
NO ONE MAKES FOR THOSE WHO
DON'T RECALL MAYBE WANNA ONE
MAKES ETHNIC STUDIES A
GRADUATION REQUIREMENT IN
CALIFORNIA IT DOESN'T MAKE THAT
GRADUATION A REQUIREMENT. OF
THE CLASS REQUIREMENT UNTIL THE
YEAR 292-029-2030 IT'S TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SO. I WOULD LIKE AN
EXPLANATION AS TO WHY WE HAVE
ALLOCATED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN THIS BUDGET FOR SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT GOING TO TAKE PLACE
FOR ANOTHER EIGHT YEARS AND
THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
MILLION IN THERE. FOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT- I
HAVE A COUPLE FOLLOW UP TO THAT
BUT IF- THAT. QUESTION CAN BE
ADDRESSED ALMOST IMMEDIATELY I
WOULD APPRECIATE THAT.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE GROUP YES
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
I'LL DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUES-
EITHER ERIN RADIO- OR BREANNA
BRANDS THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIRMAN MAY I. CHRIS FERGUSON
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
ON THIS FIFTY MILLION IT IS
SATISFIED CONTINGENT UPON THE
PASSAGE OF THAT BILL- THIS SHOW
CERTAINLY IS IT IS HELD IN
RESERVE UNDER THE EXPECTATION
THAT- YOU KNOW THERE WOULD BE A
FURTHER CONVERSATION ADDS THAT
BUILT. A WORKS THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. SO WE ARE
ALLOCATING MONEY EIGHT YEARS IN
ADVANCE. I THINK WE ARE
ALLOCATING MONEY- UNDER THE
ASSUMPTION THAT THERE COULD BE
SOME- PARTICULAR- YOU KNOW
PIECE OF THE BILL BUT THAT WORK
COULD BEGIN NOW. SHOULD THAT BE
FINE. OR BE YOU KNOW ENROLLED
OKAY- THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THAT SO THAT SOUNDS TO ME AS
THOUGH- THE ADMINISTRATION IS
LOOKING TO OFFER SOME SORT OF
CARROT. TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
START OFFERING- ETHNIC STUDIES
COURSES NOW A MUCH SOONER THAN
THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY NINE
TWENTY THIRTY- I DON'T I'M NOT
AWARE THAT WE HAVE EVER.
ALLOCATED MONEY FOR SOMETHING.
EIGHT YEARS AHEAD OF TIME FOR A
BILL THAT HASN'T EVEN BEEN
SIGNED INTO LAW- BUT THANK YOU
FOR THE CLARIFICATION. IF I
COULD ADD THAT THERE ARE LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES THAT COULD
OFFER THIS NOW EVEN THOUGH IT
IS NOT A GRADUATION
REQUIREMENT. THANK YOU. SENATOR
MAN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
WANT TO THANK THE STAFF. OUR
DEPARTMENT FINANCE AND ALSO- MY
COLLEAGUES FROM YUCAIPA AND
FROM SANTA CRUZ FOR THEIR
INCREDIBLE AND TO WORK ON THIS
BUDGET BILL- I THINK THIS IS AN
AMAZING- BUDGET AND IT WE'RE
VERY FORTUNATE TO BE INVESTING
IN A BIG WAY IN EDUCATION WHICH
AS WE ALL KNOW. IS AT THE HEART
OF OUR FUTURE AT THE HEART OF A
SOCIOECONOMIC MOBILITY AT THE
HEART OF THE AMERICAN DREAM.
AND YOU KNOW JUST FOR STARTERS
I I'M I'M REALLY GLAD TO SEE
THAT THIS BUDGET PAYS DOWN THE
DEFERRALS MADE A TICKET TO THE
K. TO TWELVE SYSTEM AND
INCREASES BASE FUNDING THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT- CHAIR LAYERED
AND I REPEATEDLY EMPHASIZED. IN
OVER THE PAST SIX MONTHS IN OUR
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION AND WHILE I
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE MANY
IMPORTANT PRIORITIES IN
EDUCATION- INCLUDING MANY THAT
ARE ADDRESSED IN THIS BUDGET.
MY BELIEF IS THAT OUR TOP
PRIORITY HAS TO BE CONTINUING
TO STRENGTHEN OUR BASIC K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION ACROSS
THE BOARD AND I CAN ONLY BE
DONE BY INCREASING OUR BASE
BUDGETS INCREASING OUR
INVESTMENTS IN L. C. S. F. N.
PROP NINETY FUNDING. SO I'M
GLAD TO SEE WE'RE DOING THAT
I'M ALSO REALLY HEARTENED TO
SEE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT. IN
PLANNING FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF UNIVERSAL T. K. WHICH IS
CRITICAL BY THE SCIENCE AND
DATE ON THIS POINT OR CLEAR
EARLY EDUCATION IS SO IMPORTANT
FOR EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES THIS
IS ANOTHER STRONG INVESTMENT IN
OUR FUTURE IN OUR FUTURE
ECONOMIC STRENGTH. THE
ROBUSTNESS OF OUR SOCIETY
INSTITUTIONS AND IT WILL ALL BE
BETTER OFF BECAUSE OF THIS
INVESTMENT I DO WANT TO RAISE
THE CONCERNS BROUGHT BY MANY
ABOUT UNIVERSAL T. K. THAT THIS
MIGHT NOT BE SUSTAINABLE OVER
THE LONG RUN THAT THIS MIGHT
LEAD TO DIS INVESTMENTS IN K.
THROUGH TWELVE IN CHILD CARE.
WHILE THIS BUDGET DOES ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS TO A LARGE
DEGREE BY MAKING LARGE
INVESTMENTS K. THROUGH TWELVE
PRESCHOOL KINDERGARTEN AND
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS. MY
BELIEF IS THAT IT'S CRITICAL
THAT WE WATCH THIS CLOSELY OVER
TIME- THE CONCERNS RAISED. HERE
ARE LEGITIMATE AND I THINK THAT
I AM GOING. OVERSIGHT AND
MONITORING ARE GOING TO BE KEY
PRIORITIES FOR. THIS BODY. TO
ENSURE THAT UNIVERSAL T. K.
OPERATES THE WAY THAT IS
INTENDED THAT DOES NOT TAX SOME
OF THE OTHER PRIORITIES IN
EDUCATION. I ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE INVESTMENTS IN
TEACHER RETENTION RECRUITMENT
AND TRAINING. IT COMING OUT A
CODE WE KNOW THESE HAPPY TOP
PRIORITIES AND I'M I'M REALLY
HEARTENED TO SEE THAT THESE ARE
PRIORITIES HERE- JUST A COUPLE
MORE THINGS I WANT TO JUST
HIGHLIGHT ABOUT THIS BUDGET
WHICH IS AGAIN SOMETHING THAT
I'M I'M- VERY PROUD TO SUPPORT.
AND IT PLAYED A SMALL PART IN
IN CREATING- ETHNIC STUDIES AN
ANTI BIAS TRAINING RECEIVE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN.
THIS IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AT
A TIME WHEN WE SEE THAT HEY IS
ON THE RISE. WHEN W SEE ANTI
ASIAN HATE IN THE STATE ON THE
RISE WHEN WE SEE ANTI SEMITIC
ATTACKS ANTI AIR ATTACKS. WE
HAVE TO PRIORITIZE EDUCATION TO
TRY TO COMBAT THIS ISSUE TO
PROTECT AND EMPOWER OUR
MINORITY YOUTH ARE MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES- THERE'S ALSO MONEY
IN THIS BUDGET TO INVEST IN A
MODEL CURRICULUM DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS FOR VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN. CAMBODIAN HMONG
HISTORY AMONG OTHER CULTURES
WHICH HAVE BEEN SHUT OUT A K.
THROUGH TWELVE CURRICULUM FOR
FAR TOO LONG SO I'M VERY VERY
PLEASED TO SEE THESE
PRIORITIZED- THESE DO MATTER
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO DON'T SEE THEMSELVES
IN OUR HISTORY BOOKS. IN IN THE
WAY THAT SCHOOLS. TEACH IN THE
STATE. I OF ENTRANCE IN
PARTICULAR AND MY DISTRICT THE
ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL. IN ADMINISTERING
THE MULTI TIERED SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT- WHICH FOCUSES ON
ALLEYS IMPLEMENTATION OF SOCIO
ECONOMIC LEARNING. DRAMA
SCREAMING AND CULTURALLY
RELEVANT AFFIRMING AND
SUSTAINING PRACTICES. AND I'M
AGAIN HAPPY TO SEE THAT THIS
BUDGET BILL. ALLOWS THEM TO
CONTINUE THEIR WORK IN THE
SPACE AND SERVE AS A MODEL FOR
THE EMPTY SS. BUT OVERALL I
THINK THIS IS A GREAT BUDGET IT
STRIKES A GREAT BALANCE IN
BALANCING OUR- SHORT TERM
CORPORATE PRIORITIES AND
THERE'S A LOT OF USE THEY'RE
VERY DEMANDING. WITH THE NEED
FOR LONG TERM INVESTMENTS WERE
TAKING THE SURPLUS AND PUTTING
A LOT OF IT INTO LONG TERM
INVESTMENTS IN OUR FUTURE. AND
I HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
SUSTAIN THESE INVESTMENTS
RESPONSIBILITY SO I JUST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU AGAIN.
TERMINATOR TWO. AS A SENATOR A
TO A VOTE. AND THE STAFF FOR
ALL YOUR HARD WORK THIS REALLY
IS AN INCREDIBLE BUDGET AND I'M
VERY VERY PROUD TO SUPPORT.
SENATOR. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
IN IT I APPRECIATE ALL THE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE COMMON AND
THE COMMENTS PARTICULARLY THAT
FOR GLOBAL THAT WERE JUST MADE
BY. THE SENATOR FROM VERMONT
BUT FROM WHAT I WANTED TO DO IS
JUST TALK AT A HIGH LEVEL ABOUT
WHAT THIS BILL MEANS AND THIS
IS ON TOP OF WHAT WE ALREADY
DID AS PART OF THE BUDGET
BECAUSE IT'S PART OF THE BUDGET
ARE WE RESTORED THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING LEVELS TO WHERE
THEY WERE PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC
AND THEN DID A FIVE POINT 7%
COAL. WE ALSO FOR THE FIRST
TIME IMPLEMENTED THE RAINY DAY
FUND WITH REGARD TO THE PROP
NINETY EIGHT SO THERE'S GOING
TO BE ROUGHLY FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS IN ASSETS AND SO IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO SAY THAT
OVERALL- WE CAME BACK AND
SURPASSED THE LEVELS BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC AND WE HAVE THE FIRST
RESERVE AN EDUCATION IN MODERN
TIMES AND THAT IS THE BACKDROP
FOR THIS TRAILER BILL- BECAUSE
THIS TRAILER BILL AND SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT- WE'RE JUST
MENTIONED I THINK ONE OF THE
IMPORTANT THINGS IS THAT- MAY
REVISE DID NOT HAVE THE
COMPLETE PAY OFF OF THE
DEFERRALS. THIS BILL HAS THE
DEFERRALS AND IT WAS ERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IF WE CAN'T
PAY OFF DEBT WHEN WE'RE AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF REVENUE IN ONE
TIME MONEY IN HISTORY WHILE I
WAIT TO HAVE A DOWNTURN AND
HAVE IT COMPETE AGAINST THE
RAINY DAY FUND. TRAILER BELOW
THIS ALSO ALLOWS THE
INDEPENDENT STUDY FOR STUDENTS
WHOSE PARENTS OR GUARDIANS
DETERMINED THAT IN PERSON'S
INSTRUCTION WOULD PUT THE
STUDENT AT RISK WE EXPECT
STUDENTS TO RETURN TO SCHOOL IN
THE FALL THAT IS OUR HOPE THAT
IS THE GUIDANCE FROM THE
LEGISLATURE BUT YES THERE ARE
PEOPLE THAT ARE WORRIED ABOUT
PUBLIC HEALTH THEY SHOULD HAVE
AN ALTERNATIVE BECAUSE
INEVITABLY WE WOULD BE FUNDING.
ARE DECLINING ENROLLMENT IF WE
PUSH THEM OUT OF THE SYSTEM
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE ENOUGH
TROUBLE MAKING SURE THAT
EVERYBODY COMES BACK IN PERSON
ARE COMING OUT OF THE PANDEMIC
AND SO IT GIVES AN ALTERNATIVE
THAT MAKE SURE THAT EVERY
STUDENTS NEEDS ARE MET- AS WE
MOVE FORWARD THIS IMPLEMENTS
THE UNIVERSAL SCHOOL MEALS
PROGRAM I CAN'T DESCRIBE HOW
SIGNIFICANT THAT IS. BECAUSE
WHAT WE FOUND IN THE PANDEMIC
AND BEFORE THAT FOOD IN
SECURITY IS A MAJOR PART OF
ISSUES IN THE SCHOOL BARRIERS
IN SOME CASES TO LEARNING THIS
ADDRESSES THAT AS WAS MENTIONED
IT EXPANDS THE TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAM AND IT
DOES IT IN A WAY. THAT IT
PRESERVES ALTERNATIVES FOR
PARENTS- IN THIS FROM OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT EXIST SO IT MEETS
A GOAL ABOUT. EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION BUT IN A WAY THAT
WORKS FROM A MENU FOR THE
PARENTS. IT ALSO AND AS WAS
MENTIONED INCREASES THE VALUE
OF THE CONCENTRATION GRANTS IT
EXPANDS CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION EXPANDS THE VIDEOS OF
THE EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR AFTER SCHOOL
AND OTHER PROGRAMS THAT REALLY
FOCUSES ON. ON ALL KIDS THAT
ARE DISADVANTAGED CATEGORIES
THAT WOULD BENEFIT FROM THIS
AND IT INCREASES SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING BY EIGHT
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
ONGOING PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING. AND IT IS A TIME
TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE WHILE THE
SUN IS SHINING. BECAUSE I CAN'T
DESCRIBE THE NUMBER OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE A ROUGH
TIME CHOOSING BETWEEN THE
COMMITMENT TO SPECIAL EDUCATION
AND THE COMMITMENT TO EDUCATION
THIS FOR THE FIRST TIME DOES
THAT SO WITH THE BACKDROP OF
THE INCREASE FUNDING BACKDROP
OF A CONTINUED PAY DOWN IN
PERSON STORES. HI THIS IS
PROBABLY THE BEST BUDGET THAT
WE WILL SEE FOR K. THROUGH
TWELVE EDUCATION IN MODERN
TIMES AND- WHILE THE QUESTIONS
THAT GET ASKED IN THIS HEARING.
ON SOME OF THE ONE TIME ITEMS
OR TINGS THAT ARE IN THIS
BUDGET ARE TOTALLY APPROPRIATE.
AND TOTALLY DESERVING OF
ATTENTION I DON'T WANT ANYBODY
TO LOSE SIGHT OF THE MAJOR OUR
PROGRESS THIS BUDGET REPRESENTS
I STRONGLY WHEN WE GET TO IT
VIRGIN I POSTED. THE THANK THE.
CHAIR FOR THE ABILITY TO MAKE
COMMENTS. THANK YOU SEPT. ONE
SENATOR LAYERED- SENATOR WHICH-
BUT GO AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MADAM CHAIR. AND THANKS
FOR THE COMMENTS FROM- MY
FELLOW. COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ATTENDED A MAN AND SENATOR
LARRY REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
WISDOM AND YOUR GUIDANCE AND
THE CONVERSATIONS WE HAD IT IN
OUR COMMITTEE FOR EDUCATION AND
WHICH MAKES ME VERY EXCITED
THANK YOU FOR PRIORITIZING THE
NEED TO PAY OFF ALL OF OUR
DEFERRALS FOR SCHOOLS THIS WAS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL I'M ALSO
VERY PLEASED TO SEE THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION PROGRAM AND CAREER
TECH THAT WAS. DESPERATELY
NEEDED. I DO HAVE ONE QUESTION
HOWEVER AND IT HAS TO DO WITH-
I'D LIKE TO KNOW. THE REASON
BEHIND THE MORATORIUM. ON NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS
IN CONTINUING AND WHAT IS THE
REASON FOR THIS DECISION. IT
SEEMS THAT FLEXIBLE TYPES OF
LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS ARE
CRITICAL NOT THE RETURNING TO
THE IN PERSON LEARNING AS WE
WERE DISCUSSING EARLIER WITH
HAVING OPTIONS AND CHOICES FOR
OUR FAMILIES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION SENATOR
I'M GOING TO TURN TO ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES VERY DETAILED
RESPONSE. ARE YOUR MUTED YOU
NEED TO ON MUTE YOURSELF. WELL
I APOLOGIZE I HAD A UNIT ON THE
COMPUTER AND ON THE PHONE
PARDON ME- ERR TODAVIA BARMAN A
FINANCE- I WOULD JUST. NOTE
THAT THE MORATORIUM ON THE- THE
OPENING EXPANSION OF NON
CONSERVATION CHARTER'S NOT
ONLY- OPERATION OF EXISTING
ACROSS THE STARTERS ARE WE JUST
KNOW. THAT AND I THINK THE
INTENT THE THINKING BEHIND THAT
MORATORIUM CONTINUALLY- IS THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN. SEVERAL CASES
A LOT OF SENSITIVITY AROUND-
THE- THE STATE AMONG
CONSERVATION CHARTERS- AND- WE
FELT THAT IT MOST APPROPRIATE
TO CONTINUE THAT MORATORIUM IN
ORDER TO CONTINUE EXAMINING-
WHAT IS HAPPENING WITHIN THE
LANDSCAPE THERE. ARE SPECIALLY
GIVEN THE PARADIGM. OF SCHOOL
NOW CERTAINLY WITH. YEAH PERSON
IS BEING THAT THE BUT AS YOU
MAY- REALITY IS THAT COMPANIES
MAY NOT BE COMFORTABLE WITH
THAT AND WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT- THERE ISN'T- TOO MUCH. OF
AN OPPORTUNITY- INTERNALLY OR
OUT FOLKS TO- WHAT I SAY TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF A SITUATION
THAT MAKES SENSE WHILE MAKING
SURE THAT WE ARE STILL
PRIORITIZING- YOU KNOW PARENTS
CHOICE AND ULTIMATELY
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS TO
THE MAXIMUM. EXTENT POSSIBLE.
THE VERY- SO LET ME SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER COMMENTS
BEFORE I GO TO THE PUBLIC-
HEARING PORTION I WOULD JUST
MAKE THE COMMENT THAT- I WANTED
TO THANK SENATOR LAYERED FOR
REINFORCING. THE VERY- HAITI
DAY AND NOT ONLY DO JUST
HISTORIC NATURE OF THE FACT
THAT WE ARE FINDING IT THE
HIGHEST A PROP NINETY EIGHT
LEVEL BUT THAT THE OTHER
ACTIONS. THAT WE TOOK IN OUR
NOT ONLY IN THIS TRAILER BILL
BUT IN OUR BUDGET ACTION
SHEPHERDED BY. OUR SUB ONE SUB
COMMITTEE. WE'RE VERY
RESPONSIBLE BUDGETING ACTIONS
LIKE PAYING OFF THE FULL
DEFERRALS HANDS PUTTING FOUR
BILLION IN THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT RAINY DAY FUND SO I
REALLY WANT TO GIVE KUDOS. TO
THE- THE LEGISLATURE FOR. THE
KID FOR ACTING IN THAT
RESPONSIBLE WAY BUDGETING IN
THAT RESPONSIBLE WAY. AN SO
THAT WE NOT ONLY ARE CREATING A
BASE BUDGET FOR OUR SCHOOLS
THAT IS BEYOND SIGNIFICANT WE
ARE ALSO ACTING RESPONSIBLY TO
PROTECT OURSELVES GOING INTO
THE FUTURE WHICH OF COURSE ALL
OF US ARE VERY- VERY CONSCIOUS
OF AND WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE DO AND THEN I WANTED TO ADD
THAT THE IN MY OPENING COMMENTS
I MENTIONED THAT WLL CHILD
CARE IS NOT IN THIS PARTICULAR
TRAILER BILL. WE DID IT WHILE
WE'RE ACTING ON THE
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN IN
THIS TRAILER BILL. WE HAVE
ACCOMMODATED FOR BOTH WE HAVE
ACCOMMODATED THE LEGISLATURE'S
BUDGET ACTION IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ACTION ACCOMMODATED FOR
BOTH CHILD CARE AND
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN AS WE
KNOW IT'S NECESSARY. AND NOT
ONLY THAT WE ADDITIONALLY IN
THIS TRAILER BILL. IS INCLUDED
THE AFTER SCHOOL IN THE SUMMER
PROGRAMS BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
OUR CHILDREN NEED. WE NEED BOTH
EDUCATION AND CARE YEAR ROUND
AND FULL DAY. SO WITH ALL OF
THE ACTIONS WILL BE TAKING.
CHILDCARE T. K. AFTER SCHOOL
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN AND THE
REST WE'RE FINALLY AT A PLACE
WHERE WE HAVE SOME HOPE THAT
MOST OF CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN
WOULD HAVE A SAFE. AND
EDUCATIONALLY RICH. PLACE TO BE
FOR AT THE TIME THAT THEY NEED
YEAR ROUND AND THAT'S VERY VERY
IMPORTANT AND THEN FINALLY WE
ARE CALIFORNIA ENACTS IN ACTING
NOT ONLY THIS BUT THE BUDGET
ACTION WE ALREADY TOOK WE WILL
BE THE FIRST STATE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT CHILDREN LEARN BETTER WHEN
THEY'RE FED WHEN THEY'RE NOT
HUNGRY AND THAT ANY CHILD COULD
SHOW UP TO SCHOOL HUNGRY IT CAN
THERE CAN BE ANY NUMBER OF
REASONS WHY CHILD SHOWS UP TO
SCHOOL HUNGRY. OF COURSE. OUR
CHILDREN WITH FAMILIES THAT
HAVE. OUR STRUGGLING
ECONOMICALLY MAYBE OUR HIGHER
LIKELY BUT ANY CHILD CAN SHOW
UP TO SCHOOL HUNGRY AND THEN
THEY'RE NOT GONNA LEARN AS WELL
AND BY THIS BUDGET WE HAVE FOR
THE FIRST TIME SAID. SCHOOL
MEALS ARE PART OF SCHOOL AND IF
YOU NEED TO BE FED YOU'RE GOING
TO BE FETED SCHOOL WHICH MEANS
THAT YOU'LL LEARN BETTER AND
THAT'S REALLY INCREDIBLE AND
WE'RE THE FIRST STATE TO DO IT
SO THERE'S MUCH IN HERE. FOR US
TO BE EXTRAORDINARILY PROUD OF
AND- I HOPE WHEN HE OPENED THE
PUBLIC COMMENT THEY AGREE BUT
LET'S SEE FIRST IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN OUR MAIN HEARING ROOM
WHO WANTS TO ADDRESS US. AND I
DON'T SEE ANY SO THEN WE WILL
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN OUR
AUXILIARY ROOM. LET'S SEE THE
NOTE SEE ANY SO THEN WE WILL GO
TO OUR PHONE LINES AND I WILL.
READ THAT PHONE LINE NUMBER
AGAIN FOR THOSE OF YOU MAY WANT
TO CALL IN. AND WHAT'S BEFORE
US IS THE BUDGET BILL JUNIOR.
WITH THOSE- FEW ACTIONS THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER CONSERVANCY. THE
FUNDING FOR THE COUNTIES FOR
THE RECALL. THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR WILDFIRE IN A
COUPLE OF TECHNICAL CHANGES AND
THEN THE K. THROUGH TWELVE-
TRAILER BILL. EDUCATION TRAILER
BILL SO THAT NUMBER IF YOU WANT
TO CALL IN AND GIVE US PUBLIC
COMMENT IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
THREE THREE SIX FOUR FOUR THREE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
EIGHT TWO SIX. EIGHT FOUR TWO
EIGHT SO MODERATOR WILL YOU
PLEASE PROCEED AND THOSE OF YOU
WERE CALLING IN APPRECIATE IF
YOU'RE VERY SPECIFIC ABOUT WHAT
THE COMMENT YOU WANT TO MAKE
AND IF YOU DO SO BRIEFLY WE'D
APPRECIATE IT. GO AHEAD
MODERATOR. PLEASE INDEMNITY
WISH TO MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I SHOULD GO TO LINE
TWO TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THIS IS FRANKLY
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR SKINNER
INTOLERANT MANY FAINTLY WITH
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA. STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY ONE THIRTY
WHICH INCLUDES FIVE HUNDRED AND
FORTY SEVEN MILLION
APPROPRIATION FOR THAT EIGHTEEN
G. COMPLETION IMPROVEMENT GRANT
PROGRAM TO IMPROVE COLLEGE
ACCESS FOR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
WE WANT TO ESPECIALLY THANK ON
OUR RADAR FOR HER COMMITMENT TO
GETTING MORE CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS. ON THE PATH TO
SUCCESS AND THAT THEY ARE WELL
PREPARED AND ABLE TO ACCESS
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR COLLEGE
EDUCATION THANK YOU. NEXT WE GO
TO LINE TWO FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON NATALIE
HOW LITTLE TIME WITH WIDENING
GROUP SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
NEXT GEN CALIFORNIA. BRIEF
COMMENT WE AND COMPLETELY
SUPPORT THAN THAT THANK OF THE
FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION IN ONE TIME
PROCTOR NEED FINE FOR THE
EASTER G. COMPLETION
IMPROVEMENT GRANT PROGRAM IN
EIGHTEEN ONE THIRTY. WE THANK
THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
INCLUSION OF THE COUPLE ON THE
BUDGET THAT WILL SUPPORT
STUDENTS. IN ATTAINING HIGHER
EDUCATION. PROSPEROUS THANK YOU.
NEXT TO THE TO LINE TO SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI AARON HAPPY
WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATE THE ONE I
THINK THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR YOUR
TREMENDOUS WORK ON THE
EDUCATION BUDGET EIGHTY ONE
THIRTY WENT DOWN THIS YEAR
CALLED FOR ROBUST INVESTMENT
RACIALLY JACK'S RELATIONSHIP
CENTERED COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
REFLECTED IN A THREE BILLION
PROVIDED FOR THE COMMUNITY.
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM WE APPLIED
TO MORE THAN TWO BILLION
ALLOCATED FOR CRITICAL EDUCATOR
RECRUITMENT TRAINING AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TO
ATTRACT AND SUPPORT DIVERSE
WELL PREPARED TEACHERS WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE CHANGES TO THE SEA
BASS TO PERMIT QUALIFYING
COURSE WORK TO DEMONSTRATE
SUBJECT MATTER PROFICIENCY.
WITH THE FOR THE INCREASE TO
THE OFFICE OF CONCENTRATION
GRANT EXPANDED STATE FOR
CLARIFYING THE LAW AND
IMPROVING THE OUTCOME TEMPLATE
TO ENSURE THE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS GENERATED ANNUALLY BY
LOW INCOME STUDENTS ENGLISH
LEARNERS NEED AFTERCARE ARE
USED AS INTENDED TO INCREASE OR
IMPROVE SERVICES FOR THOSE HIGH
NEEDS STUDENTS. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE GREATER
TRANSPARENCY BEING REQUIRED
FROM ALLIGATORS AND THEY'RE ALL
COMING UP THE OTHER PLANS THAT
HE HAS A SUPPLEMENTAL FEE AND
FEDERAL STIMULUS FUNDS.
AMOUNTING TO THIRTEEN BILLION
IN OUR BOETTCHER THREE FINES
AND BILLIONS IN CATEGORICAL
FUNDING LASTLY WE SUPPORT THE
MORE THAN SIX MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT TO HELP DISTRIBUTE
SCHOOL CLIMATE SURVEY TO
IMPROVE LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
BUILT FORD USING THIS
UNPRECEDENTED OPPORTUNITY TO
REIMAGINE OUR SCHOOLS AND
ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSES OF
EDUCATIONAL AND EQUITY IN
CALIFORNIA I THANK PLACE IS.
LOOKING FOR GAMBLING THANK YOU
AGAIN. THANK YOU. NEXT TO THE
TO LINE TO THE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE DOCUMENT ON UNDER BECAUSE
FOR POPPED OUT WHAT'S CANNOT
LONG PASS. ARE GOING TO COME
ANOTHER ARE ME TO IF YOU KNOW
SCHOOL. AND CRITICAL THOUGHT TO
BE ABLE TO ACT PARKER MARCH
REGARDLESS OF IF YOU LOOK AT
KONTRON AND TO ENSURE THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO ASSIST IN FIGHTING
HUNGER ARE. HERE IN CALIFORNIA
GIVEN A CHANCE. THANK YOU.
MEXICO TO LINE TWO OH ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS KARINA LIGO SEVEN
JOURNEY AT THE CHILD CARE LAW
CENTER ALL FAMILIES NOT JUST
THOSE WITH FLORAL NEED CHILD
CARE. EVERY FAMILY. AND EVERY
FAMILY HAS DIFFERENT NEEDS.
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY TRAILING THE
LANGUAGE ENSURING PARENTS
CHOICE FOR PARENTS WITH
SUBSIDIES HOWEVER WE CANNOT
REPORTED AND SO THERE IS A NO
COST UNIVERSAL MAKES DELIVERY
OPTIONS FOR ALL FAMILIES AND
IT'S SEQUEL DEFINING GROUP THAT
INCLUDES THE PEOPLE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY T. K. EXPANSION
AARON AND SHOCK OF THE WRITERS
AND PROGRAM. AND THEN ALSO BE
AT THE TABLE IN PLANNING. AND
IMPLEMENTATION THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR GOING TO LINE TWO OH
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
STANDARDS BRITANNICA ROGER
ELLIOT CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
CONSORTIUM WHICH IS A NON
PROFIT ALLIANCE A LICENSED HIGH
QUALITY CHILD CARE AND
PRESCHOOL PROVIDERS- TOGETHER
WE OPERATE- OVER FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY CENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA- EMPLOYEE OF
APPROXIMATELY NINE THOUSAND
EDUCATORS AND STAFF. AND
THROUGH OVER FORTY THOUSAND
CHILDREN HERE IN CALIFORNIA IN
ART HE- IN R. ETT CENTERS AND
WE ARE UNFORTUNATELY CALLING IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY ONE THIRTY
TODAY BECAUSE OF THAT
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROPOSAL. DOES NOT INCLUDE ALL
PROVIDERS AND IS LIMITED TO
ONLY GO UP TO A PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM AND AS YOU JUST HEARD
FROM THE CHILD CARE A LOT
THINNER WE CAN NOT TO SUPPORT A
PROPOSAL THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE
ALL PROVIDERS ZERO MAKES
DELIVERY SYSTEM SO THAT. ALL
PARENTS AND CHILDREN CAN
RECEIVE CARE IN WHATEVER
SETTING WORKS BEST. FOR THEM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. NEXT TO THE LINE TWO
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS JEANNIE GILBERT AND I'M
A FOSTER MOM ORANGE COUNTY AND
I WANNA THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
WORK YOU PUT INTO THE BUDGET
BUT I AM VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE PROPOSED CHANGES THE
INDEPENDENT STUDY AND CHARTER
SCHOOL I DON'T THINK THAT THE
WAY IT'S WRITTEN WITH THE
MOBILE- COUPLE BUT THAT NO
ACTUALLY THE- DETECTION AND
HELP. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT TO THE TREE LINE TWO OH
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
CATHERINE O'HALLORAN WITH THE
TECHNICAL DEVELOPMENT CENTER WE
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN ABOUT
THE POOR QUALITY OF DISTANCE
LEARNING PROVIDED BY MANY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS BUT THE
AMENDMENT PROPOSED IN THE
TRAILER BELL ARE BURDENSOME AND
IT'S DIRECTED. AT HIGHLINE
NUMEROUS NEW REQUIREMENTS ON
LONGSTANDING INDEPENDENT STUDY
PROGRAM. WE URGE IT NEEDS TO BE
SIGNIFICANTLY PARED BACK AND
ANY ADDITIONAL COMPLIANCE
BURDEN TO PLANT THAT AT THE END
OF THE CALL AND THEN. WE ALSO
URGE AMENDING THE CRIMINAL
PROVIDE EQUITABLE FUNDING FOR
NON CLASSROOM. BASED CHARTER
SCHOOL THANK YOU. MEXICO TO
LINE TWO OH SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI I AM BETHANY CANTRELL-
APPEARANCE OF LONG TIME
INDEPENDENT STUDY STUDENTS. AND
I'M OPPOSED TO THE PROPOSED
CHANGES TO THESE PROGRAMS
INCLUDED IN AB ONE CURTAIN
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO OH TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS SCOTT DAVIS AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS FOR THE PARENT
ASSOCIATION A GROUP OF
THOUSANDS OF PARENTS TO
MOBILIZE THAT SPRING TO
SUCCESSFULLY SUED THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. TO REOPEN OUR SCHOOLS
I'M CALLING TO OPPOSE EIGHTY
ONE THIRTY WHICH WILL CURRENTLY
ALLOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO ONCE
AGAIN CLOSE DOWN AT ANY TIME
FOR ANY REASON AND ONLY REAL
OPEN AGAIN WHEN THEY DEEM IT
POSSIBLE. THE SINGLE BIGGEST
FAILURE OF THIS LEGISLATURE
PERHAPS IN THE HISTORY OF THE
BODY WITH ITS FAILURE TO
MANDATE AND ENFORCE THE
PROVISIONS OF LAST YEAR'S AT
THE NINETY EIGHT. THAT SCHOOLS
QUOTE MUST OFFER IN PERSON
TRACTION TO THE GREATEST EXTENT
POSSIBLE UNQUOTE. THIS
AMBIGUOUS LANGUAGE ALLOWED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE TO INVENT ANY NUMBER OF
REASONS WHY IT WAS NOT POSSIBLE
TO OPEN SCHOOL. RESULTED IN
MOST SCHOOLS STAYING CLOSE ALL
YEAR. IN CALIFORNIA RANKING
FIFTIETH IN THE NATION FOR
SCHOOL RE OPENING DURING THE
PANDEMIC. WHILE EVERY OTHER
STATE IN THE COUNTRY SAFELY-
OPEN MORE SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA. OUR STUDENTS IN
THIS STATE SUFFERED IMMENSE
LEARNING LOSS COUPLED WITH THE
EMOTIONAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES FROM BEING ISOLATED FROM
THEIR TEACHERS AND PEERS WHILE
ADULTS ON BACK TO WORK. DINED
AT RESTAURANTS AND SOCIALIZE IN
BARS. DESPITE NUMEROUS COMMENTS
FROM LEGISLATORS THE DISTANCE
LEARNING IS ENDING IN SCHOOLS
WE BACK IN PERSON THIS SCHOOL
YEAR SP ONE THIRTY CREATES
PROVISION THAT ALLOWS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO UNILATERALLY
CLOSED SCHOOLS ANYTIME THEY SEE
FIT FOR A PANDEMIC. WE TURN
THAT HAS NO DEFINITION CASE
THRESHOLD OR PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER INVOLVED IN THE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS. THEN
IT ONLY REQUIRES SCHOOLS TO
REOPEN QUOTE AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE UNQUOTE. THE SAME
MEETING THIS REQUIREMENT ARE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS RED LEAGUE
NORTH LAST YEAR WHEN THEY KEPT
TELLING PARENTS IT WASN'T
POSSIBLE TO REOPEN SCHOOLS. THE
AUTHORITY TO CLOSE AN OPEN
SCHOOL DURING AN EPIDEMIC
SHOULD ONLY RESIDE WITH THE
COUNTY OR CITY HEALTH OFFICER
AND SHOULD BE BASED ON CLEAR
THRESHOLDS OF CASES THAT IMPACT
THE ABILITY OF CHILDREN TO BE
LEARNING IN CLASSROOMS. IF THIS
IS NOT MADE CLEAR IN EIGHTY ONE
THIRTY. CALIFORNIA WILL BE
DOOMED TO ANOTHER YEAR OF MASS
SCHOOL CLOSURES WHICH WILL
FURTHER HARM OUR CHILDREN AND
THE PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA. IF THIS OCCURS
AGAIN PARENTS WILL KNOW EXACTLY
WHO TO HOLD RESPONSIBLE. IN
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY TWO
THANK YOU. MEXICO TWO NINE.
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
SHELTER PHARMACOLOGY. BUT IT
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF A
GROUP OF FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN FAMILY. PROGRAM CHANGES
THAT INDEPENDENT. ONE THIRTY
DRASTICALLY CHANGED HER. SOME
OF THE YEAR THE- THANK YOU. SO
THE TWO NINE TO FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JONATHAN IS ACKERSON WE OPEN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS I'M CALLING
IN OPPOSITION TO AB ONE THIRTY
AND ITS CURRENT FORM FOR THE
SAME REASON THAT START DATE OF
YOUR LAST YEAR THAT THE
LEGISLATURE FAILED AT.
PROVIDING CLEAR LANGUAGE IN
SCHOOLS TO OPEN TO STAY OPEN
UNTIL TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
OPEN AT THIS STILL DOES THE
SAME THING WE NEED STRONGER
LANGUAGE TO MAKE SURE THAT
SCHOOLS WILL BE OPEN AND CANNOT
BE ABUSE FROM THE PLANKTON
LANGUAGE. ESPECIALLY THE OPEN
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE DURING A
PANDEMIC WE SAW THAT WENT LAST.
YEAR AND IT WOULDN'T WORK.
THANK YOU. THANKS TO GO TO LINE
TWO EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NOT A
PROBLEM AND I REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION THE BODY
SHOULD BE APPLAUDED FOR. THEIR
TECHNICAL EDUCATION MY COMMENT
TRANSACTION TWENTY FOUR ARTICLE
NINE. REVIEW COMPLETION GRANTS
ARE YOU COULD YOU CALL THE
OFFICE TO REVIEW THAT SHOULD BE
REPORTED TO ALL STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. OPPORTUNITY SHOULD
NOT COME IN FOR THAT PARTICULAR.
TECHNICAL EDUCATION CLASSES. I
NAME'S SCHOOL DISTRICT YOU HAVE
TO G. G. WAGE SHOULD SUPERSEDE
THE BRIDGE ARE UP BECAUSE-
THERE IS NO. OF YOU WANT FOUR
NINETY. DESCRIPTION THE COTTAGE
OR PROGRAM TO OFFER MORE ISSUES
REQUIRE. ORDERS RECEIVED
ADDITIONAL TALK. ACTIVITY G.
CLASSES WITH SPECIAL TO ALL
CALLED FOR HIS BILL MAHER. FROM
EQUAL BENEFITS OR SIMPLY OR AT
MINIMUM FOR BUILT INTO THE
LANGUAGE. THE OPPORTUNITY ARE
ALSO QUITE TO TRADE THAT THE
DOGS THANK YOU. MAKE SURE TO
LINE TO TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHERINE
FREEMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES WE SUPPORT THE
FINDINGS IN EIGHTY ONE SIXTY
ONE FOR WILDFIRE PREVENTION BUT
WE ALSO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WE
SUGGEST WORKING CLOSELY WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND WHERE THE
FRONT LINES OF WILDFIRES AS
THEY BECOME MORE DANGEROUS
UNITY THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
FUNDING DOES NOT NEED TO GO
THROUGH CAL FIRE BUT COULD BE
ALLOCATED TO REGIONAL AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OR OTHER FIRE
PREVENTION PARTNERS THAT WE CAN
APPLY FOR FUNDING AND WE CAN'T
SPEND FUNDING WITHOUT SOME SORT
OF PROGRAM OR PLAN. COMPANIES
ARE PREPAREDTO JOIN ANY
CONVERSATION THAT WILL ENSURE
THE FUNDING IS USED TO SUPPORT
OUR COMMUNITIES WE LOOK FORWARD
TO THE CONVERSATION AND QUICK
ACTION ON THE ALLOCATION OF
WILDFIRE FUNDING AND THANK YOU
SO MUCH. FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON
THIS DIFFICULT SUBJECT. THANK
YOU. MEXICO TO LINE ONE NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL I
MEAN I THINK UNITY LEADER AND
PARENTS LONGTIME INDEPENDENT
STUDENT THE NAME OF THE
PROPOSED CHANGES TO THE PROGRAM
INCLUDED IN EIGHTY ONE THIRTY
THANK YOU. MEXICO TO LINE TO
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS JUDY BURL I'M
A PARENT AND I'M A RETIRED
TEACHER FROM SAN LEANDRO
UNIFIED- APPLAUD THAT-
UNPRECEDENTED FUNDING THAT'S
GOING TO GO TO OUR SCHOOLS
HOWEVER I. NINE OPPOSITION TO
AB ONE THIRTY RELATIVE TO
SECTION FIFTY EIGHT. WHICH
GRANTS AN AUTOMATIC TWO YEAR
EXTENSION TO CHARTER SCHOOL
RENEWAL BECAUSE OF LACK OF
STANDARDIZED TEST SCORE DATA.
DISTRICTS NEED AUTHORITY TO
EVALUATE CHARTERS BASED NOT
ONLY ON THAT DATA BUT ALSO ON
THEIR FISCAL SOLVENCY
GOVERNANCE AND OTHER IMPORTANT
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES AND
EIGHTY FIFTEEN OH FIVE
SPECIFICALLY STATES THAT
STANDARDIZED TESTS SHALL NOT BE
THE ONLY MEASURE BY WHICH TO
MEASURE- CHARTER SCHOOL
PERFORMANCE. SO I URGE THAT
THAT- SECTION FIFTY EIGHT WHICH
WOULD ADD SECTION FOUR SEVEN
SIX OH SEVEN POINT FOUR TO THE
END CODE BE OMITTED FROM-
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY THANK YOU.
MEXICO TO NINE TWO TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
CATHERINE CREDIT ON POLITICAL
RELATIONS ON BEHALF OF YOUR
GROUP SECOND LARGEST FOR PROFIT
CHILD CARE PROVIDER IN NORTH
AMERICA WE'D LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION STARSHIP IN
OPPOSITION TO THE CURRENT
DESIGN OF THE U. KI K. PROGRAM.
WE BELIEVE THERE WILL BE
SIGNIFICANT UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN SEEN IN OTHER STATES.
THANK YOU. MEXICO TO LINE TWO
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ANDREA BALL ON THE HALF
OF THE EXPLORATORIUM IN SAN
FRANCISCO WANT TO THANK THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE FOR ALL THE
WORK AND THE RESTORATION OF
FUNDING FOR THE K. TWELVE
SCIENCE LEADER NETWORK. AND THE
HIGH QUALITY PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT OFFERED BY THE
EXPLORATORIUM ON SCIENCE
EDUCATION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THERE'S ONE MORE MOMENT. I WILL
GO TO LINE TWO TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JESSICA
CODY AND I'M A PARENT OF LONG
TIME INDEPENDENT STUDENT AND I
AM OPPOSED TO THE LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL OF EIGHTEEN AND THIRTY
ONE THIRTY REGARDING THE
INDEPENDENT STUDY CHANGES- TO
THE INDEPENDENT STUDY PROGRAM-
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY SUCH
CHANGES ARE OCCURRING WHEN THE
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN WORKING. FOR
MANY YEARS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MODERATORS AND THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU. THAT'S THE LAST
ONE OKAY SO- WE'VE NOW RECEIVED
OUR PUBLIC COMMENT WE'VE GOT-
AS I INDICATED TWO BILLS BEFORE
US LET'S GO TO THE FIRST ONE
WHICH IS A B. ONE SIXTY ONE. SO
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
MEN ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
BEFORE WE DO A ROLL CALL ON AB
ONE SIXTY NINE THE BUDGET
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR. ONE MOMENT.
OKAY I SAID AB ONE SIXTY ONE
DID NOT. SO I DIDN'T OKAY SORRY
AB ONE SIXTY ONE THAT IS WHAT
WE'RE VOTING ON ROLL CALL
PLEASE. AB ONE SIXTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS SENATORS
SCANNER HI SKINNER HI E.
NIELSEN. YES AND NO COPYRIGHT
COURTESY COURTESY HI DOLLY
KELLY HI THE RAZA PRESIDENT HI
AIKMAN. GROVE COM LONGER COME
LONGER HI LAYER. LAYERED HI
BUYER. HEY MAN I. MELINDA'S
MELINDA'S NO MAN. MAN HI NEWMAN
NEWMAN HI THE TROUBLE I HAD
TROUBLE HI IN. STERN STERN HI
WHAT COUNTS SKI MY CASKEY I.
NIELSEN NOTRE HI. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN- AND WE
WILL GO TO THE NEXT BILL.
APOLOGIES GO AHEAD SENATOR
MELINDA I GOT THE WRONG GIRL
THAT WAS ONCE MELINDA'S. NO
DOUBT HI. RIGHT SO AS I
INDICATED I'M GONNA KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN SO AND BECAUSE I HAVE
A FEW MISSING MEMBERS SO I'M
GONNA GO TO THE NEXT BILL WHICH
IS OUR EDUCATION TRAILER BILL
AB ONE THIRTY I THINK I GOT
THAT ONE RIGHT AND IT'S MOVED
BY SENATOR LAYERED AND BEFORE I
TAKE THE ROLL CALL. SEEING NO
MIKE'S LET'S DO A ROLL CALL ON
H. B. ONE THIRD. AP ONE THIRTY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS SENATORS
SCANNER HI SKINNER HI NIELSEN.
NO SIR NOT VOTING. COPYRIGHT
CORTESE CORTEZ THE I. DALI ALI
NO THE RAZA RUSSELL HI. EGGMAN
SEGMENT HIGH GROWTH. COM LOGGER
COME LONGER HI LEHRER. LEHRER
HI REQUIRE. MELINDA'S LINDA'S
NO MAN MAN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN HI
THE TROUBLE. T. MOBILE HI PENN
DAN HI STERN- HI KELSEY
MCCASKEY HI. ALL RIGHT LET'S
WORK KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN LET'S
JUST RE OPEN THE RULE ON THE
FIRST BILL WHICH IS AB ONE
SIXTY ONE IT'S CALLED THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. I THINK THERE'S
AT LEAST ONE ABSENT MEMBER IN
THE ROOM. AB ONE SIXTY ONE THE
MOTION WAS TO PASS COPYRIGHT.
GROWTH MCGUIRE CAN CAN I. OKAY
R. N. DR PAN YOU GOT TO VOTE ON
THE SECOND BILL CORRECT. YEAH
N. MISSED SENATOR STERN YOU GOT
TO VOTE ON BOTH BILLS CORRECT.
YEAH YES OKAY SO- HI HOLD ON
ONE SECOND.
UHHUH UHHUH. HELLO
TO. STILL THERE OKAY OKAY.
ALL
RIGHT WE WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
OUR FIRST BILL THE BUDGET BILL-
JUNIOR WHICH IS BABY ONE SIX
ONE GO AHEAD MR STEPPING SHARI
CAN OPEN THE ROLE FOR THE
OPPOSITE NUMBERS. A. B. ONE SIX
ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
COPYRIGHT. CAMARO HIGH GROWTH
MCGUIRE RIGHT NOW WE WILL- SO
SORRY AB ONE SIXTY ONE IS OUT
WITH. SIXTEEN FIVE VOTES AND
NOW WE WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON P.
B. ONE THIRTY THE K. TWELVE
EDUCATION TRAILER BILL. AP ONE
THIRTY THE MOTIONS TO PASS.
SENATORS COPYRIGHT CABRERO HIGH
GROWTH ENQUIRE. RIGHT AB ONE
THIRTY IS OUT AND THAT IS
THIRTEEN. THIRTEEN TWO. NEVER
FILLS OUT RIGHT THANKS SO MUCH
WITH THAT. WE'VE GOT OUR BILLS
OUT AND THE SENATE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE WILL
ADJOURN.